EMERGENCY AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORTH PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL WITH
SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. ALTHOUGH
TODAY WE HAVE NO MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THAT WE
HAVE DOCTOR RICHARD PAN HERE
PERSON ANSWER MELINDA'S WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO JOIN US TODAY.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR YOUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. WHILE
YOU'RE SPEAKING TO US THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
RECOGNIZE IT USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
FIFTEEN YOUR TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO AND MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT AND YOU BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK. PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WILL BE USING A TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
CALENDAR. IT WILL THIS BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE FIVE EIGHT. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FIVE ZERO
FOUR ZERO SEVEN FOUR. DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO USE THAT
TELECOM SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE- AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS A
TESTAMENT AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE. AND TODAY'S HEARING
WILL REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS RELATING TO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES AND THE OFFICE OF
EQUITY AND CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. I WILL NOTE
THAT ALL ITEMS IN THE AGENDA
WILL BE UP FOR DISCUSSION BUT
THE COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE
VOTING ON ANY ITEMS TODAY ALL
ITEMS WILL BE LEFT OPEN. WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. AT THE END
OF THE HEARING AFTER ALL ITEMS
HAVE BEEN HEARD- NOW WE BEGIN
WITH THE FIRST AGENDA ITEM.
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENT
METHODOLOGY STUDY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES. WE WELCOME THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EXPLAINED TO
BE HERE FOR YOU AT THIS
AFTERNOON. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BEFORE TO ONE POINT ZERO SIX
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET FOR THE
TRANSFER PROGRAM THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX MILLION OF WICH IS
STATE GENERAL FUND. DECSS
PRIORITIES CONTINUE TO BE ON
THE EQUITABLE FUNDING ACCOUNTS
FOR PROGRAM ACROSS ALL THE
LOCAL TRANSFER AGENCIES THE
COURTS AND STATE DECSS. WE WERE
ON TRACK TO ACCOMPLISHING THIS
FOR AN IMPENDING BUT LIKE MANY
OTHERS CODE IS RESULTING IN THE
SET BACK TO THOSE EFFORTS. THIS
BUDGET SEEKS YOU TO TRANSFER
PROGRAM BACK ON TRACK TO
ACHIEVE THOSE OBJECTIVES.
ALBEIT AT A SLOWER RATE. SO
WITH YOUR PERMISSION I'D LIKE
TO TURN OVER CONSTANT ENGINE OR
TO. GIVE A. QUICK OVERVIEW THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. I THANK YOU MY NAME
MENTIONED IN THE SERVER- THANK
FOR TO GIVE A OVERVIEW ON THE
BUDGET CRITICAL UNDERGARMENTS
ARE YOU CAN GET DATA TO ADDRESS
THE FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE
CHALLENGE FOR PROGRAM WHICH IS
JUST TRUST WATER AND ALONG.
IMPACT THAT HAS THAT HAS ON. I
SHOWN IN FIG ONE OF THE AGENDA
THERE'S ABOUT EIGHTEEN FIVE
DOLLARS ACHIEVING HELP ARREARS
MOST OF WHICH IS SHOWN IN DELTA
MORNING BRACKET. BETTER POINT
YOU SHOULD. THE PROPOSAL SEEKS
TO ADAM JOHN MY IT CAN. IS
APPROPRIATE FOR PARENTS THAT
HAVE UP IN OTHER WORDS IS THE
LOVE OF SUPPORT FOR YOU INCOME.
SET AT A LEVEL THAT IS. FOR
PAYING. YOUR CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS ARE SET TOO HIGH.
RELATIVE TO A PARA INCOME IN
LEAD TO THE CAN OF CHILD OR-
WHEN THE PAIN PARENT'S OWN.
BASIC SERVICES TO CHALLENGE. WE
HAVE A YEARS COMPROMISED BUT
WE'RE STRONGER A COKE. SHOULD
PROVIDED OPPORTUNITY FOR
PARENTS REDUCE THEIR GOVERNMENT
DEBT AND- WAY. YOUR GENDER
BECAUSE ALL THAT IN. FOR
CHANGES DIFFICULT PROGRAM BUT I
WANT TO- GO HIGHER. ANOTHER
ASPECT THE PROPOSED WHICH IS
LOOK AT WHAT ACT. IMPACT TO
COLLECT. OF GEARS.
APPROXIMATELY ONE. OF THE
GOVERNMENT I WOULD BE ARE. TO
GLASCO FORTY DOLLARS DOLLARS IN.
INCOME COLLECTIBILITY LOW AT
THE TERM. AND HOW THE BILL TO
READ THIS. OR HOW DID ACTUALLY
BECOME. GARDEN WHICH YOU ARE IN
THE ESCAPE. SUBJECTING THEM TO.
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AS LIKE THE
DETENTION. AND GOOD FOR ALL OF
US TOGETHER DANTICAT AT. BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW AS WELL. ON THE
MY COLLEGE POTECT PROPOSAL AND
HAVE THAT YOU CAN QUESTION TO
THE COMMITTEE. ALL THE- IF SO
WE'LL GO TO THE PARTNER FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS ON.
HELLO. RIGHT JACQUELINE BRACERO
JACQUELINE BRAZIL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE NO
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL WOULD ECHO STAFF
COMMENTS OF ENSURING THAT THE
STUDIES DO NOT DUPLICATE
EXISTING RESEARCH BUT RATHER
PROVIDE NEW INFORMATION- TO
MOVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
FORWARD- WE WOULD ALSO SUGGEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REQUEST A
DRAFTOF THE RESEARCH PROPOSAL
TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF
WHETHER THE LINE OF QUESTIONING
OR HOW THE TOPICS ARE FRAMED-
ALIGNED WITH THOSE OF
LEGISLATIVE. INTEREST BUT
TAKING A STEP BACK AND LOOKING
AT THE PROPOSAL MORE BROADLY WE
WOULD ALSO SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE VIEW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESEARCH
PROPOSAL AS A OPPORTUNITY OR OF
POTENTIAL VEHICLE TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS. OF EXISTING OR
NEW PROGRAM POLICIES THAT HAVE
COME UP IN PASSED BUDGET
HEARINGS AND LEGISLATIVELY
DRIVEN WORK GROUPS THAT COULD
BOTH FURTHER INFORMED THE STATE
APPROACH IN IMPLEMENTING AND
MAKING CHANGES- TO ALIGN WITH
THE FEDERAL FINALRULE. OR TO
JUST DISCUSS POSSIBLE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PROGRAM AS
A WHOLE I'M AND AN EXAMPLE WAS
PROVIDED TO IT- IN YOUR GENDER
IN THAT- THERE HAVE BEEN PAST
CONSIDERATIONS BY THE
LEGISLATURE I'M TO SEASON FORCE
MEN ON CHILD SUPPORT DEBT OWED
TO THE STATE THAT IS DEEMED
UNCOLLECTIBLE. AND THUS IS NOT
AN EFFECTIVE OR PRODUCTIVE USE
OF PROGRAM RESOURCES IF THE
LEGISLATURE STILL INTERESTED IN
PURSUING THAT SPECIFIC-
OPERATIONAL CHANGE AND ITS
ATTEMPTS TO MANAGE AND REDUCE
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT. I'M BECOME
CONSIDER INCLUDING THAT- AN
ASSESSMENT ABOUT PARTICULAR
CHANGE WITHIN THE RESEARCH
PROPOSAL WITH THAT SAID WILL
CONTINUE TO ASSESS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FOR ALL AND
WILL SHARE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS WE HAVE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IF I CAN
ASK BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT. IN
THIS I'M NEW TO THIS SO VERY
BRIEFLY CAN YOU SPELL.
EXPLAINED TO ME THE K. FACTOR.
ON THE LINE IS KRISTIN DONNELLY
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR THAT CAN
GO INTO THAT DETAIL OF THE MORE
CLEARLY. SURE JOHNSON IS BASS
ON A MATHEMATICAL. AND THE KEY
FACTOR IS A COMPONENT TO THE
PERCENTAGE OF A PARENT'S INCOME
THAT IS UTILIZED FOR CHILD
SUPPORT. SO THE CURRENT K.
FACTOR IS ZERO POINT TWO FIVE
OR 25% AS A BASE OR AS AN
ANCHOR AND SO THAT MEANS WITHIN
CERTAIN BANDS OF INCOME FOR
FAMILIES AND IT'S COMBINED
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. WE ASSUME
THAT FOR ONE CHILD WE'RE GOING
TO ASSIGN 25% OF THE PARENTS
INCOME TO SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN. OKAY THE LAST REPORT
HAD RECOMMENDED FURTHER
RESEARCH ON THE K. FACTOR AS IT
HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED AND THE
BANDS OF INCOME HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE IT WAS PUT INTO
PLACE IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE.
SO WILL WILL THAT BE PART OF
THE STUDY THEN IS TAKING A LOOK
AT THE KEY FACTOR IN SEEING IF
IT'S STILL ACCURATE AND
RELEVANT AND THEN HOW DOES THAT
HOW WE- HOW WE USE THOSE TWO
DATA POINTS. THE C. O. A. P.
THE KEY FACTOR- TO REACH A
CONCLUSION JOURNAL WE HAVE ANY
OTHER DATA POINTS OR ANY OTHER.
METHODOLOGY THAT WILL BE IN AND
INTEGRATING INTO THAT. YES
THERE COUPLE DIFFERENT RESEARCH
METHODOLOGIES- ALREADY IN
PLACE. THAT NEED TO BE UPDATED
SO THAT TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT
WHICH WAS PRODUCED- BY JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA AND- GIVEN
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. DID RECOMMEND
FURTHER RESEARCH ON THAT K.
FACTOR- WE DO WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK MORE BROADLY. AND
GENERALLY THE IDEA IS THAT IF
WE HAVE AN ORDER THAT IS TOO
HIGH AS NAN SAID THEN WE COULD
LEAD TO ARREARS. SO THERE'S
THAT TIPPING POINT FOR PARENTS
OF WHERE IT BECOMES TOO MUCH
AND NEITHER PARENT CAN SURVIVE.
SO IT IS ALSO INTERCONNECTED IN
TERMS OF DETERMINING THE
SUBSISTENCE LEVEL FOR THE
PARENT WHO'S PAYING SUPPORT AS
WELL. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
IN THE PROCESS OF KICKING OFF
THEIR QUADRENNIAL REVIEWS EVERY
FOUR YEARS REQUIRED TO DO A
REVIEW. SO THEY WILL GET AGAIN
BE LOOKING AT AND THE RESEARCH
THAT'S ALREADY IN PLACE AND
WHETHER ANYTHING NEW HAS TAKEN
PLACE SINCE THAT LAST REVIEW
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SO WHAT
WE'RE PREPARING FOR IS THE
BELIEF THAT THEY WERE ASKED TO
DO FURTHER RESEARCH ON THIS AND
SO WE CAN PARTNER WITH THEM TO
DO THAT TOGETHER. SO WILL THERE
BE ANY WHAT WHEN THEY JUST COME
OUT WITH THEIR THEIR PATERNAL
REVIEW. HOW HOW. WOULD YOU
PROPOSE AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DONE SO WE'RE NOT
REDUNDANT AND- DOING THE WORK
DISCARDED INTO BY ANOTHER
AGENCY. ABSOLUTELY THAT'S A
HUGE GOAL FOR US WE DON'T WANT
TO BE WERE DONE IN THIS
RESEARCH SO. THAT QUADRENNIAL
REVIEW AND THE SCOPE OF THAT IS
NOT LARGE ENOUGH TO DO ANY
ORIGINAL RESEARCH WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO DO HERE TO GET
A BETTER IDEA FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE REPORT FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TALKS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA SO UNIQUE. AND
THAT IT IS THE DIFFERENCE- IN
ALL THE DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
STATE WHERE HUGE STATE AND-
IT'S VERY VERY DIFFERENT SO
IT'S VERY DIVERSE. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
APPROPRIATE RESEARCH TO
UNDERSTAND- F WE DO NEED TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE
MORE CUSTOMIZABLE. AND IF WE
CAN DO THAT. MAKE IT UP THAT
WOULD NOT BE REDUNDANT THE
ACCORD JOINING REVIEW WOULD SAY
HERE'S THE RESEARCH. THAT'S IN
TOTAL AND WE RECOMMEND YOU DO
FOR RESEARCH ON THIS IS. SO
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON. THE FURTHER RESEARCH
NEEDED TO GONNA TAKE DIRECTION
FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
REPORT WELL SO THAT REPORT IS
DUE TO JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN
NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR AND IT
WILL COME TO GO TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO START
OUR RESEARCH AFTER WE KNOW
FINALLY WHAT THEIR REVIEW THAT
COMES STEVEN JERRY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT THEY RECOMMEND THAT
WE RESEARCH FURTHER IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THEY DID RECOMMEND
FURTHER RESEARCH ON THE KEY
FACTOR AND THAT'S NOT BEEN DONE
YET SO WE ANTICIPATE THAT THAT
WILL BE IN THIS NEW REPORT AS
WELL SO WE'RE NOT ANTICIPATING
EVEN GETTING GOING ON THIS
UNTIL NEXT YEAR IS THAT
CORRECT. FOR THE K. FACTOR
PORTION YES WE WOULD LIKE TO
START WITH THE COLLECTABILITY
PORTION HERE WE DID ANTICIPATE
THAT THIS RESEARCH WOULD NEED
TO BE DONE OVER TWO YEAR
PERIODS THAT'S WHY DOES HAVE
THAT TWO FISCAL YEARS IN THIS
PROPOSAL OKAY. AND THEN- LET'S
FIND OUT WHAT THE BEST PLAN. I
YOU THINK IT'S A VERY- SO
BASICALLY PAY SOMEONE A- JERRY
SAYING THAT FOR THIS COMING
FISCAL YEAR THE PROPOSAL IS
REALLY TO STUDY TO
COLLECTABILITY ISSUES AND THEN
AFTER JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS DONE
THEIR REPORT THEN YOU'RE GONNA
LOOK AT THE K. FACTOR IS SO IS
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES
BOTH PARTS ARE IS IT JUST FOR
THE FIRST PART. OF YOUR STUDY.
IT'S FOR BOTH PARTS IN URBAN
OKAY SO BOTH PARTS OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN WHAT IS YOUR
LOOKING AT THE COLLECTABILITY
ISSUES SO FOR EXAMPLE- YEAH WE
DID HAVE A BILL WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY GOVERNOR VETOED.
REGARDING INTERESTS I THINK BUT
I REMEMBER WHEN THE BILL CAME
THROUGH HUMAN SERVICES ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
IS THAT SOMETIMES- PEOPLE. IF
ONCE THE PUBLISHERS LIKE WHEN
THE DATE GETS VERY LARGE IN A
LARGE PORTION OF THAT DEBT
ACTUALLY IS NOT TO PAY THE FOR
THE CHILD SUPPORT IT'S TO PAY
THE PENALTIES AND INTEREST AND
SO FORTH. THAT PEOPLE MUCH MORE
RELUCTANT TO PAY IT BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE THAT MONEY ACTUALLY
GOING TO THEIR CHILD. IS THAT
ISSUE GOING TO BE EXAMINED IN
YOUR COLLECTIBILITY REPORT TO
THE ISSUE ABOUT- PEOPLE'S
WILLINGNESS TO ACTUALLY PAY
WHAT'S IN ARREARS. GIVEN WHAT
THEY MAY KNOW ABOUT THE PORTION
OF THE FUNDS IT ACTUALLY ENDS
UP WITH THE CHILD- THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING CHILD SUPPORT FOR.
YOUR QUESTIONS IN ADVANCE OF
THE- COMPROMISE ARREARS PROGRAM
IS A PROGRAM THAT WE ARE
REVAMPING TO EXPAND OUT AND THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD- BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT OPPORTUNITY.
THE LIMITATIONS OF THE CO
PROGRAMS THOUGH ARE THAT A
PERSON HAS TO PUT FORWARD A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY TO GET
AND A LARGER AMOUNT RE REMOVED
FROM DEBT. TO BUILDINGS ARE HE
REALLY WANTS TO GO ONE STEP
FURTHER AND LOOK AT CASES
WHERE. THERE IS NO ABILITY TO
PAY AND HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THOSE WITHIN SOFTWARE
PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW ONLY
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THOSE IS TO
CLOSE THE CASE ENTIRELY AND
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
SOMETHING WE'RE ABLE TO DO
WITHIN OUR CURRENT FRAMEWORK OF
RULES. THEM RIGHT NOW SO I
THINK THIS WILL INFORM SOME OF
THE DECISIONSTHAT NEED TO BE
MADE ON THE ROAD ON HOW WE GET
RID OF. AND ACTIVISTS TRULY
UNCOLLECTIBLE IN ITS ENTIRETY
OKAY SO I GUESS I WOULD URGE
THAT WE EXPANDED THE SCOPE OF.
THIS STUDY- THAT YOU'RE DOING-
INSTEAD OF JUST NAY MORE NOW.
LOOKING AT JUST PEOPLE WHO.
CAN'T PAY THEIR DAD. TO
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THE LARGER
ISSUE OF- HOW DO WE MAXIMIZE
OUR COLLECTION. RATE WHICH IS.
TECHNICALLY WHAT THE WHOLE
STATE WAS ABOUT INCLUDING
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE K. FACTOR
BUT REALLY LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE ISSUES. GUARDING- YOUR
ABILITY TO COLLECT FROM P. I
MEAN CERTAINLY WE WANT TO LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENS TO PEOPLE WHO
QUOTE YOU KNOW CAN'T PAY IT AT
ALL RIGHT NOW BUT ALSO WANT TO
LOOK MORE BROADLY AT HOW HOW DO
WE- YOU KNOW HOW DIFFERENT ARE
DIFFERENT MECHANISMS WE HAVE
THAT WE PUT IN PLACE LIKE
WHETHER IT'S INTEREST OR
PENALTIES AND SO FORTH MAY
ACTUALLY IMPACT PEOPLE'S
WILLINGNESS. TO PAY BACK THEIR
DEBT I THINK IT'S A CRITICAL
QUESTION BECAUSE ULTIMATELY.
WHAT WE WANNA DO IS WE WANT TO
MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT. CAN GO TO THE CHILD AND
THEIR FAMILY I MEAN THAT'S
HOPEFULLY THAT'S THE GOAL OF
CHILD SUPPORT GREAT AND- WE
SHOULD REALLY BE LOOKING AT
THAT ISSUE AS WELL AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT KIND OF POLICIES THAT
WE PUT IN PLACE THAT MAXIMIZES
THE FUNDS THEY'RE GOING TO.
CHILDREN AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
BY DOING THAT WE HAVE TO REDUCE
OTHER STATE EXPENSES AS WELL
RIGHT SO WE KNOW IF YOU'RE THE
KIND OF WORKS AND KNOW THAT
IT'S ADDRESS SO- SO I GUESS I
WOULD URGE THAT THE SCOPE OF
YOUR STUDY BE BIT BROADER THAN
SIMPLY JUST LOOKING AT THE-
POPULATION OF PEOPLE WHO. BACK
AT THE POINT WHERE THEY'RE
UNABLE TO PAY AT ALL AND LOOK
MORE BROADLY AT SERVE
COLLECTION PRACTICES. AND HOW
THAT IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO
COLLECT PEOPLE'S WILLINGNESS
AND HOW MUCH EFFORT WE HAVE TO
TAKES TO TRY TO TEASE PEOPLE
DOWN TO GET THEM TO PAY- IN
THAT REGARD SO- I HOPE THAT.
THAT WHEN YOU COME BACK TO US
UP AND MADE WITH THIS PROPOSAL
THAT YOU BE A BROADER. STUDY
WOULD BE AND ANTICIPATED. A
GOOD COMMENTS IN THAT IS THE-
WE'RE TO GO AND THEY'RE ALL
REALLY. INTO PLAY. IN CONNECT
TO KATE FACTOR NOT DATING MAX
IS REALLY TRYING GET ENACTED
ORDER SO THAT READERS DON'T
BUILD UP. THE COLLECTABILITY
SAID HE'S REALLY LOOKING AT
ALRIGHT WHAT'S ALREADY BUILT UP
AND HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT
NIGHT IT'S KIND OF ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CASES- WE
HOPE TO ADDRESS IN THIS. THANK
YOU AND THEN OF COURSE THE
FINAL IMPACT ON CHILDREN
FAMILIES- SO I GUESS I WOULD I
WOULD ASK. SINCE THE IT WAS THE
GOAL OF THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
TO GET RID OF IT ALTOGETHER-
AND IF YOU'RE JUST STARTING TO
FIND. OUT HOW WE BEST- CAN. ON
IT TO MAKE SURE THERE'S ENOUGH
MONEY FOR. CATCHER AND
FAMILIES. IF WE CAN PLEASE ASK
YOU. TO COME BACK WITH THE FULL
SCOPE OF THAT SO WE CAN PERHAPS
PROVIDE SOME MORE INPUT ON WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE INCLUDED.
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
NOT QUITE SURE YET IF IT'S
GOING TO BE A DATA COLLECTION
TOOL OF PROCESS. EVALUATION AND
LIKE TO SEE THE KIND OF THE
COMPONENTS OF THE OF THE
RESEARCH GOING FORWARD BEFORE
WE- MOVE FORWARD. OKAY THERE'S
NOTHING ELSE WE WILL MOVE ON.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE WE WANT TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT COURT AND FUNDING.
THANK YOU HAVE MENTIONED GIVEN
A- PROPOSAL HI NANCY MENTIONED
THAT APARTMENT- AUGUST FIRST
ALTHOUGH THE GENDER GIVE A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF THE LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT- COURTS AND CHILD
SUPPORT FUNDING PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
APPROACHING TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOUR POINT ONE YOUNG
JOHNNY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
CONTRACT THE GENERAL COUNCIL
WHICH FUNDS LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
YOU MISTER MARKETS CARTER OUT.
OF ALL GOING TO BE INDEPENDENT
KOBE THE PROPOSAL RECALL-
ANOTHER COMPONENT WHICH IS
ELEVEN POINT AND NINE DOLLARS
YOUR GUIDE PERSONAL OPERATING
COSTS ELEVEN TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS CRITICAL IT STAFFING
OPERATING COSTS NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THE CHILD SUPPORT
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM GOING
FORWARD AND ADDRESS THE YOU
DEMAND OF A TELEWORKING
WORKFORCE AND MANAGER. AND
FUNDING TO MANAGE DEPARTMENT
IDEA OF THE STRUCTURE. HAS THE
EIGHTY EIGHT YEAR PROGRAM A
PROGRAM A COUPLE BY THE CAR
EFFECTIVE FOR TO LEAGUE INCOME
AND EDUCATE FAMILY LAW
SOLICITORS AND GIVES CURRENT
ACTIVE TO THEIR LOCAL COURTS TO
LITIGATE TROPICAL CASES HOWEVER
AGAIN AB PROGRAM LED TO AND BY
STAFF THE COST. AT THE GYM THE
POINTS OUT THAT BECAUSE OF THE
OF THE AND ONLY ON BILL
CRITICAL USED TO BE DOWN AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE TO REDUCE OUR
THE LOCAL CORPS INTRODUCTION TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR TO
GET EDUCATE. AND LOOK UNDER
BELIEVE ASPECTS OF A CHILD'S
PROGRAM THROUGH THE.
WE HAVE NO
IMMEDIATE CONCERNS AT THIS TIME
WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE QUESTIONS
OUT TO JUDICIAL COUNCIL-
INCLUDING HOW THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING MAY HELP LOCAL COURTS
ADDRESS. COBIT NINETEEN IMPACTS
ON CHILD SUPPORT COURT
OPERATIONS AND SERVICES- WHEN
WE HEAR BACK WE'RE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO REPORT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF ON ANY
ADDITIONAL INSIGHTS- WE GAME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH AND I
GUESS THAT WOULD BE MY QUESTION
TO IT IS SO IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'RE GONNA USE A LOT OF THIS
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD TO GO TO A
MORE VIRTUAL. TECHNOLOGY THAT
BASED SERVICE- AND JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY. THAT. WE'RE ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING THAT AIM. THANK OKAY.
I THINK THAT WE WRAP UP THEN I
NUMBER TWO. MOVING ON TO. ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. LOCAL TELL
SUPPORT FUNDING. HI NANCY
REQUIREMENTS- THE DEPARTMENT
ACROSS TWENTY NINETY THE FUN
THE TWENTY LOWER- LOS WANTED
LOOK WHICH HOW SUPPORT AGENCY
ON THE COUNTY GEORGIA I'D BE ON
THE FUNDING METHODOLOGY WHICH
WOULD TO. ON BACK COULD YOU AND
I- ORTEGA'S TEACHER COUPLED
WITH THE REDUCTION THAT THE
COUNTY TOOK IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA OKAY
KATHY HAD DECREASED BY ALMOST
ONE OF POSITIONS OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND IT APPEARED TO DECLINE
FURTHER IF YOU FUNDING IS NOT
RISKY. INCREASE IN STOPPING IT
HAPPENING AT A TIME WHEN
PARENTS ARE MOST IN NEED ABOUT
THREE FOUR TO THE DEPARTMENT
CASELOAD ARE EITHER CURRENTLY
OR ONLY A FAMILY THE FAMILY HAS
BEEN DEEPLY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC- I DID YOUR JOB LOSS
OR REDUCTION IN INCOME. THE
CHANGES AND FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES REQUIRE MORE
MODIFICATIONS TO CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS ARE OFTEN A LABOR
INTENSIVE WORK WITH LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT STAFF. AND WORK WITH
THE CURRENT DISPUTE THOSE
MODIFICATIONS THE PROPOSAL IS A
STEP TOWARDS DEPARTMENTS
REQUIRE YOU TO ADDRESS FUNDING
EQUITY ACROSS ALL LCT COUNTY BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL CLINICAL
LOW. TWENTY COUNTY. HELP TO
BRING ALL CAN CULTURE.
COMPACTLY. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS WHERE. OKAY WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT ANYTHING. HELLO
ADDITION COMES THANK YOU WHICH
WOULD ANALYSTS. WE NO CONCERN
WITH THE FUND GOVERNMENT- WHICH
FIRST ALSO YOU MAY PAR RESTORED
FUN. I'M THAT WERE ELIMINATED
AS A PARTY THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ALSO WE HAVE
NO CONCERNS WITH- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH AND
DIRECTING THE FINES I'M TO
THOSE L. CSAS THAT PER ITS OWN
CALCULATION DO NOT HAVE THIS
NECESSARY STAFFING LEVEL TO
FULLY MANAGE CASE WORK- WE
WOULD KNOW. THAT WELL THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECENTLY
DEVELOPED FUNDING METHODOLOGY
FOR LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES INCLUDES MULTIPLE
FUNDING AUGMENTATIONS IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT DUE TO
PROJECTED BUDGET CONSTRAINTS
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
PROPOSING. I'M ANY ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATIONS IN FUTURE YEARS-
WHILE THE STATE MAY NOT BE THE
BEST FISCAL POSITION TO COMMIT
TO THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AUGMENTATIONS. THE STATE MAY
STILL BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS THEIR
OPERATIONAL OR POLICY BASED
CHANGES I'M SPECIFICALLY THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
EXPLORE- WHICH OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES ARE POLICY
CHANGES. IT COULD PURSUE WHILE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FUNDING
METHODOLOGIES ON BECAUSE I'M IT
COULD DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION
TO EVALUATE- POLICY CHANGES AND
EFFICIENCIES THAT WERE RAISED
AND PREVIOUS WORK GROUPS
PILOTED IN SOME LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES- EVEN
PREVIOUSLY CONSIDERED BY THE
LEGISLATURE OR ADMINISTRATION.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT BE- LEGISLATURE DIRECTED
MINISTRATION- TO ADDRESS ANY
CONCERNS- THAT WERE RAISED AND
IT'S RECENTLY DEVELOPED A LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES BEFORE
REPURPOSING THIS. BEFORE
REPURPOSING. THE METHODOLOGY IN
FUTURE YEARS. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH I GUESS I JUST WOULD ECHO
THAT AND ASK THE QUESTION THE
DECISION A- FIRST OF ALL HAVE
WE SEE. WHAT RESULTS HAVE WE
SEEN FROM THE DECREASE THAT WE
FACED WITH WITH COVERT. AND
WHICH OF THE EFFICIENCIES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR PRIOR
STUDIES ON THIS ARE WE
INTEGRATED INTO THE INTO THE
QUESTIONS IN THE METHODOLOGY OF
THE NEW STUDY. THIS IS A
REGULAR WHAT SOME OF THE
PRIMARY ISSUES THAT ARE MOVING
FORWARD ON AND RETRIEVE ALL
AROUND THE ELECTRONIC DELIVERY
OF DOCUMENTS PARTICULARLY. A
SIGNATURE WITH COURTS AND
THERE'S A BIG MOVE IN THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM AND FOR TELL
WORKING AND THE REDUCTION OF.
PRINCE THE ENTIRE STATE FOR A
LITTLE TRANSFERASES AND STATE
DECSS. AND WE ALSO HAVE SMALLER
INITIATIVES THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THE TRAINING AND
MAKE TRANSPORT MORE EFFICIENT-
OUR MIGRATION TO THE CLOUD OF
OUR TRANSFORM FORTUNE SYSTEM.
AND WE EXPECT TO SEE SOME
SAVINGS OFF OF THAT HOPEFULLY
AND IN THE WAY THAT WE RENDON
OPERATOR SYSTEM. AND BEYOND
THAT THERE ARE SMALLER TWEAKS
IN THERE ARE LOCAL BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE BEING.
UTILIZED ACROSS THE STATE BUT
THEY'RE NOT SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL CHANGES THAT THAT
GREATLY IMPACTS THE OVERALL
OPERATIONS ALSO PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM ITSELF IS GONE THROUGH
ALMOST TWO DECADES OF LACK OF
FUNDING AND EFFICIENCIES ALL
ALONG THE WAY A LOT OF ISSUES.
STATE FARM WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO. THIRTY I THANK YOU THREE
MUCH AND- I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION AND THE GOVERNOR'S
AT LEAST PROPOSAL. TO END TO DO
REALLY SOME INCREASE HOWEVER I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO PART HILLS WE
CAME TOGETHER AND WE HAD CHILD
SUPPORT DOWN COUNTY CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION COME TOGETHER
AND DEVELOP- THE PROPOSAL THAT
SAID FUNNY PROPOSAL WHICH IS
SAID DON PIES AND BAKERY
SHOOTER SOME INCREASE THIS
YEAR. NOTE THAT AS WE WERE
EXAMINING THAT- THAT. THAT THAT.
WE ACTUALLY END UP BY FULLY
INVESTING GENERATING MORE MONEY
FOR CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES
THAN BY NOT AND SO I DO WANT TO
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS WERE QUOTE-PUTTING A PIES BECAUSE THE
ULTIMATE IMPACT AT LEAST FOUR
WE LOOK AT IT SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WAS IS THAT- OUR LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN- CHAU IT
INCIDENTS HAPPEN THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES IN A CHILD
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE ACTUALLY
ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN
ESSENTIALLY CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES GETTING LESS RESOURCES
I MEAN THAT'S THE REASON WE
HAVE CHILD SUPPORT IN FACT AT
THE BULLS DON'T. TRY THINK HOW
LONG W. EVEN AT SOME POINT WE
WERE PENALIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BY HAD PADLEY WE
WERE DOING SO WELL I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT THERE IS SOME
INCREASE THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
AND I THINK PROPERLY TARGETED I
GUESS I WOULD ALSO APPEAL SAY
THAT- WE REALLY SHOULD BE
TRYING TO WORK TOWARD FULLY
FUNDING WHAT WE AGREED TO
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND IF WE
CAN'T DO IT THIS YEAR- WE
SHOULD AT LEAST IN THE OUT
YEARS BE LOOKING AT ME THAT
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THIS IS
ABOUT TRYING TO MAXIMIZE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING WE CAN GET TO
CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES THROUGH
THE CHILD. SUPPORT SYSTEM AND
I'M AFRAID THAT BY PUTTING A
PIES- IF WE CONTINUE TO STAY IN
A PAUSE MODE WERE ACTUALLY
GIVING UP ARE ACTUALLY GIVING
UP WE ARE DECREASING WHAT WE
WERE ANTICIPATING WE'RE ABLE TO
DO SO- I GUESS I WOULD URGE
THAT- VOICE ONLY APPRECIATE
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE IF
IT'S POSSIBLE TO TRY TO
pCERTAINLY AT THE YEARS WE
SHOULD BE PLANNING TO FULLY
pPROPOSALS THAT WE CAME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
NOT THAT MANY YEARS AGO AND- SO
THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDS WE'RE GETTING TO LAST
TWO CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES.
FOR TO CHILD SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR SEVEN TWO ALREADY BROUGHT
UP. THE SIGNATURES HERE WE GO.
I KRISTIN X. NINETY FOUR THE
DEPARTMENT- THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PERMITS US TO UTILIZE.
OUR EXISTING RESOURCES IN TERMS
OF AN ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE TOOL
IT CREATES AN EXCEPTION TO THE
GENERAL RULES FOR USAGE OF
THOSE ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES IN
COURT FILINGS AND IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH A LONGSTANDING
EXCEPTION ALREADY IN PLACE FOR
A LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES.
WITH REGARD TO DOCUMENT SIGNED
BY THEIR AGENTS. THE GENERAL
RULE IS THAT DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
SIGNED ELECTRONICALLY CAN THEN
BE FILED ELECTRONICALLY. THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BUILDS
UPON THAT AND BUILT UPON AN
EXPANSION FROM THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IN THE RULES OF COURT.
THAT WAS EFFECTIVE IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH PERMITS
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE AND
DOCUMENT SIGNED BY OPPOSING
PARTIES AGAIN OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS ARE ELECTRONICALLY
FILED. HOWEVER ONLY ABOUT
TWENTY COUNTY COURTS HAVE
ELECTRONIC FILING CAPABILITY AT
THIS TIME. AND EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY WE SOUGHT TO UTILIZE OUR
EXISTING ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE
TOOL AND THAT NEW RULE OF COURT
TO PERMIT THOSE LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES WITH
ELECTRONIC FILE CAPACITY. TO
CIRCULATE DOCUMENTS TO PARTIES
TO JUST DISTILLATIONS. SO WE
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THAT TOOL TO
THOSE LTSA IS- WITH THE
EXPANDED NEED FOR MODIFICATION
DUE TO COPE WITH THOUGH WE WERE
ABLE TO ADD A FEW MORE COUNTIES
ON THAT- ACCEPTED OR ADOPTED
EMERGENCY RULES OF COURT. TO
PERMIT THIS KIND OF PAPER
FILING OF THOSE DOCUMENTS SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DOES IT PERMITS US TO
CIRCULATE THOSE DOCUMENTS SUCH
AS STIPULATIONS- FOR ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURE AND THEN IF THEY
COUNTY COURT DOES NOT HAVE
ELECTRONIC FILE CAPABILITY. FOR
THE LOCAL AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO
PRINT THAT DOCUMENT AND HAVE IT
FILED SO GREATLY REDUCES THE
TIME IT TAKES TO CIRCULATE
THESE DOCUMENTS. AND WE'RE
GONNA BE HAPPENING SAID THAT
SYSTEM UP. YES WE ALREADY HAVE
THIS AVAILABLE FOR ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE COUNTIES SO IT WOULD BE
JUST PROVIDING ACCESS TO OUR
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE TOOL TO
THE REST OF OUR COUNTIES
EVENTUALLY WE WOULD UTILIZE OUR
EXISTING STATEWIDE. OUR SYSTEM
TO BE ABLE TO SEND THOSE
DOCUMENTS THAT WE CAN SEND IT
THROUGH THE SIGNATURE TOOL
TODAY SO THAT'S WHY THERE'S NO
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE TODAY
SO IT'S A MORE LOW TECH
APPROACH- TO BE ABLE TO GET
EVERYBODY ACCESS TO THIS AND
HAVE THAT STATEWIDE CONSISTENCY
SO. IN EVERYBODY IN ANY COUNTY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO UTILIZE THIS
TOOL RATHER THAN ONLY A SELECT
FEW. I APPRECIATE THAT
SPREADING IT OUT FOR EVERYONE
TO BE ABLE TO BE THE BEST OKAY
THE- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HORN- NOTHING FURTHER
TO ADD THANK YOU. HELLO THIS
TIME. THE CONCEPT OF EXPANDING
THE ALLOWANCE OF ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURE WAS IDENTIFIED AS A
BEST PRACTICE IN OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCY IN THE PREVIOUSLY
LEGISLATIVELY DRIVEN WORK
GROUPS- SO WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL BUT WHAT
AGAIN REITERATE THAT- IN
ADDITION TO THE EXPANSION OF
THE SIGNATURE. IN THE END THERE
IS STILL A QUESTION OF ARE
THERE OTHER PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES THAT- WERE
DISCUSSED IN THESE WORK GROUPS
THAT COULD ALSO BE EXPLORED AND
MAYBE JUST TO MAKE IT A FULL
CIRCLE MOMENT- WE'RE IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT ARE THERE
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN LOOK AT
COLLECTABILITY MORE BROADLY.
I'M SPECIFICALLY IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ULTIMATELY
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR THAT TRY
TO LOOK AT THE PRODUCTIVENESS
AND COST EFFICIENT
EFFECTIVENESS OF PURSUING-
CHILD SUPPORT ARREARS BACK-
WERE DEEMED UNCOLLECTIBLE. AND
THAT WAS A- THE PROGRAM
EFFICIENT THAT WAS DISCUSSED IN
THESE WORK GROUPS- SO TO THE
EAST AND I'M DEPENDING ON HOW
YOU STRUCTURE IT COULD POSSIBLY
ALSO RESULT IN SOME WORKLOAD
RELIEF- AND COST PRESSURE
RELIEF TO LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES IT BACK MEANS THAT-
THEY'RE NOT. THEY'RE NO LONGER
PURSUING- COLLECTIONS FOR THOSE
CASES I'M SO AGAIN THAT'S JUST
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE COULD- CONSIDER
EXPLORING ADDITIONAL PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES BLANKING SIGNATURE
THAT WERE MENTIONED AND
DISCUSSED IN PREVIOUS WORK
GROUPS. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS I
THINK WE'RE GOOD TO GO AND I
THINK YOU'RE ON TO READ THE
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT
RELATING TO CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES- AND I SHOULD SAY THAT
GENERALLY WE HAVE ADVOCATES
PRESENT THEIR PROPOSALS. FOR
INVESTMENT SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
TIME. YEAH YEAH LET'S. PROPERTY
I YES WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
SUSPENSION OF PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVES AND THEN YOU'LL BE
UP AND OUT AND ALLOWS- THEM IT
FOR THE FOR THIS ITEM AND GOING
FORWARD IF THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING
TO ADD PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL CALL ON YOU IF NOT I
WILL NOT A THAT THE SAME FOR
THE ILLEGAL. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ISSUE NUMBER FIVE TWO
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT. THANK
YOU- MANSION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- DISPOSAL IS TO
COMPLETE CONTINUE THE
SUSPENSION OF FAMILY CHURCH AND
CHURCH I'M HERE SIX-
POTENTIALLY THIS- STATUE THAT
THEY- ARE GOING TO CENTER
PROGRAMS. HAS BEEN SUSPENDED
AND CONSTANTLY TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO- ONE O'CLOCK EXTENDED
THERE'S A PERCENT JUMP ON
LIABILITY- ACTUALLY- PROVIDE
ENTERTAINMENT SHOULD THE TOP
TEN PERFORMING ON STAGE-
DEPARTMENT STILL WORKING ON-
COMING UP WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
MODEL. AND OVER THE COUNTRY.
APOLOGETICALLY. TIME THAT
GINGER THANK YOU. OKAY IN ELSE
THE BOARD ANYTHING FROM APART
FINANCE I DO NOT SEE YOUR HAND
UP ANYTHING FOR THE L. A. O.
PLEASE- NOTHING THERE OKAY- ALL
RIGHT THEN I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT COMING BEFORE US THAT
SOONER THAN LATER OKAY DR
ANTHONY THANK GOODNESS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
IF WE COULD HAVE THE L. A. O.
PLEASE READ THE PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT RELATED TO CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES. YES WE WERE
ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE TO READ
THE EXTERNAL BUDGET PROPOSALS-
WE WILL MAINLY BE READING THE
TITLE IN THE BRIEF DESCRIPTION
OF THE PROPOSAL AS IT'S
PRESENTED IN THE AGENDA. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THESE ARE NOT
ONLY A PROPOSALS AND MANY OF
THE ISSUES ARE RELATIVELY NEW
TO US OUR ABILITY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS MAY BE LIMITED. BUT
WE ARE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF TO GET
ANY ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PROCEEDS. OF SO AS IT RELATES
TO THE CHILD SUPPORT PROGRAM
THERE IS ONLY ONE EXTERNAL
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN THE AGENDA.
SPECIFICALLY THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REQUEST
NINETEEN POINT TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONGOING WHICH IS
MATCHED WITH. THIRTY SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS TO SUPPORT LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW WE MOVE
ON TO. DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES OFFICE OF EQUITY
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE MY
NAME'S ELIANA CAME ONCE I WILL
BE PROVIDING THE RESPONSE TO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE REGARDING THE
OPEN NINETEEN RAPID RESPONSE
EXPENDITURE- FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
IMMIGRATION RAPID RESPONSE.
FROM THE BROADER COPING
NINETEEN BUDGET CHANGED SO IT
IS INTENDED TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
STAFF FUNDING FOR A QUICK
RESPONSE TO EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS. WHERE IMMIGRANT
POPULATIONS WERE IN ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED SERVICES
OR BENEFITS CAN RECEIVE
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE.
STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR THIS
RAPID RESPONSE PROGRAM WAS
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IMPROPER INSTITUTIONS
CODE SECTIONS. 1-300-040-0213
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND NINE
IT AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE HUMANITARIAN RESPONSE
TO NUMEROUS SITUATIONS
INCLUDING NATURAL DISASTERS
ABRUPT FEDERAL POLICY CHANGES
AND PANDEMICS WHERE INDIVIDUALS
MAY NEED SHELTER FOOD AND
MEDICAL SCREENING CLOTHING OR
OTHER BASIC SERVICES. LAST YEAR
THE DEPARTMENT SET UP THE
DISASTER RELIEF ASSISTANCE FOR
IMMIGRANTS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
ONE TIME CASH ASSISTANCE TO
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
IMPACTED MAKEOVER NINETEEN
WOULD NOT QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
STIMULUS OR OTHER FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS. THIS PROGRAM
DISTRIBUTED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TO PARTNERSHIPS. WITH OUR
NONPROFIT PARTNERS. IN ADDITION
THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN CLOSED.
WITH NONPROFIT YOU COUNTY
PARTNERS IN SOUTHERN IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BORDER
REGION MONITORING THEIR RIVALS
OF IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ALLOWED
TO ENTER. IN THE PAST RAPID
RESPONSE PROGRAM FUNDING HAS
BEEN USED TO HOUSE THE WRITING
FAMILIES AND PROVIDE FOOD
MEDICAL SCREENING AND
TRANSPORTATION AS NEEDED TO
INSURE SAFE AND WELCOMING AND
TREAT PROCESSES NOT THE BORDER.
RIGHT BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR RAPID
RESPONSE FUNDING. BASED ON THE
REALITY THAT WITH THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC ANNUAL NATURAL
DISASTERS IMPACTING YOUR RATE
POPULATIONS INELIGIBLE FOR FEMA
FINDING. AND THE SITUATION AT
THE BORDER THE DEPARTMENT WILL
NEED FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
TO SITUATIONS IMPACTING OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. GIVEN THE
POTENTIAL INCREASE IN IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES ARRIVING AT CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN BORDER AND THE ON
GOING. PANDEMIC THIS WILL ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO RESPOND IN A
BOTH MANAGE INTERNATIONAL
MONETARY WAY AND ENSURE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE HAVE
APPRECIATED THE FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDED BY THE CURRENT
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK THAT HAS
ALLOWED US TO SHIFT FOCUS AS
THE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION POLICY
HAS CHANGED. OVER THE PAST FOUR
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PREVENT. THE PROGRAM TO FOCUS
ON TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
DEFERRED ACTION FOR CHILDHOOD
ARRIVALS PUBLIC CHARGE IS
NEEDED TO RESPOND TO THE NEEDS
ON THE GROUND. AS ALWAYS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION POLICY
CLOSELY TO ENSURE WE ARE
RESPONSIVE TO ANY CHANGES. AT
THIS TIME HOWEVER IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT WHAT TYPE
TYPE OF ADDITIONAL SERVICES MAY
BE NEEDED FOR THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THE SERVICES WOULD
REQUIRE. THANK YOU AND I FORGOT
TO INTRODUCE MYSELF MY NAME IS
ELIANA CAME ONCE I AM THE
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION BRANCH
CHIEF HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
ANYTHING FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. I DON'T SEE YOUR HAND
ANYTHING FROM THE L. A. U. OKAY
IT YES. I'M OKAY I GUESS I
GUESS I WOULD JUST A- ASK SAID
THAT SO NONE OF THIS MONEY IS
GOING TO BE USED FOR DIRECT
PAYMENTS. TO PEOPLE THIS TIME
IT'S JUST GOING TO BE USED FOR
SUPPORT AND ALL THAT SUPPORT BE
PROVIDED. THROUGH A GRANT
PROCESS TO NONPROFITS OR HOW
WILL WE DECIDE HOW. TO
DISTRIBUTE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND TO WHOM. THANK YOU FOR THAT%
QUESTION. OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THIS TIME THAT THE FIVE
MILLION IS- IS INTENDED TO
RESPOND TO ANY SITUATION THAT
ARISES SO IT MAY BE- AT SOME
POINT YOU SHOULD AS A DIRECT
PAYMENT MAY ALSO BE USED FOR
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES OF OUR
NONPROFIT PARTNERS AS NEEDED-
WEEK WE DON'T QUITE KNOW AT
THIS TIME WHAT. EXACTLY AT THE
EMERGENCY THAT WILL BE AWESOME
IT WILL BE- SO WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE SPECIFIC DETAILS BUT IN
THE PAST IS MENTIONED IT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED FOR AN EVER IDEA
SERVICES INCLUDING SHELTERING.
DIRECT ASSISTANCE OPERATIONAL
EXPENSES TO PROVIDE ANY OF THE
SERVICES. AND USUALLY WE HERE
AT THE- INTEGRATION BRANCH WORK
WITH- NONPROFIT SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND PROVIDE GRANT
LEGAL AGREEMENTS AND. AND GET
THE FINDING OUT NOT MATTER. SO
WE'RE NOT SURE YET IF THIS WILL
BE THROUGH RAN FUNDING. WE'RE
NOT SURE. WE'RE NOT SURE BUT
THAT IS USUALLY THE METHOD THAT
WE USE HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT
TO ALLOCATE THE FUNDING TO OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS. OKAY SO THIS
IS A QUESTION JUST IN CASE. AND
DOES THE DEPARTMENT ANTICIPATE
WITH THE NEW FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT MIGHT BE COMING THAT THIS
WILL ANYTHING WILL BE OFFSET. I
THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
UNCERTAINTIES AT THIS POINT WE
ARE. STILL WAITING TO SEE WHAT
TYPE OF FEDERAL PROGRAMS OR
FUNDING WILL BE WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE- BUT WE HAVE IN THE
PAST NO IN THE STATE HAS BEEN
ASKED TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSES TO WAIT THAT IS THE
INTENT OF THIS FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO PRINT. TO RESPOND
QUICKLY. OKAY I THINK THE PART
FULLY APPROVE THIS WOULD LIKE
SOME MORE INFORMATION DR GRANT.
THANK YOU- YOU MENTIONED THAT
LAST YEAR OR TWO OR SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION I REALIZED IT WAS
A- PLOT THAT NOT JUST STATE
MONEY WAS- OTHER TYPES OF
MONIES- DO YOU ANTICIPATE FOR
THIS COMING YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
ALSO BE GETTING HELP FROM NOT
FOR PROFITS AND OTHERS. IN THE
SAME SCALE AND THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER QUESTION IS THAT WHAT IS
TRUE REPORTING REQUIREMENT I
REALIZE YOU CAN'T ANTICIPATE
RIGHT NOW BUT ONCE YOU EXPAND
THE FUNDS. IS A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IS HOW THE FUNDS
WERE EXPENDED- ONCE IT'S- DONE
ARE OR- SELF SERVICE BOTH OF
THOSE QUESTIONS. QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
PRINT THAT WAS. PROVIDED LAST
YEAR FOR THE DISASTER RELIEF
ASSISTANCE FOR IMMIGRANTS FIND
IMMIGRANTS PROGRAM WAS STATE
FUNDING- AND WE DID PROVIDE A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. LAST
YEAR IN THE FALL- WITH. DETAILS
ON HOW THOSE FUNDS WERE
EXPENDED- THAT WAS A
COMBINATION OF FUNDS TO PROVIDE
OPERATIONAL SUPPORT THE
NONPROFIT'S DELIVERING THE
SERVICE. AS WELL AS THE
DIRECTOR SYSTEMS PAYMENTS TO
INDIVIDUALS- NOT SURE DR PANDA
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION BUT I HAD
A FOLLOW UP. YES WELL ACTUALLY
MY QUESTION WHAT IS THE SENATE
OKAY SO. THIS IS SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR AND FIVE
MILLION- AND I YEAH I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT FLEXIBILITY
IS THERE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AS TO HOW YOU WENT THE FOR THE
FIVE MILLION THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING THAT ONCE IT'S
EXPENDED THAT. THE THAT WILL
ALSO BE REPORTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE. OTHERS FUNDS WERE
EXPENDED. YEAH WE DO PROVIDE.
WE DO EXPECT TO PROVIDE REPORTS
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
EXPENDITURE OF THOSE FUNDS.
OKAY AND- ALL RIGHT THAT'S-
DIDN'T DESERVE- OKAY. THAT'S
RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY AND SINCE
I'M I'M TO THE COMMITTEE HAVE
HAVE WE USED ALL THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT WAS ALREADY
THERE. IS THAT A QUESTION YES
I'M SO YES THAT WAS A QUESTION
FOR YOU. HI YES WE HAVE THOSE
FUNDS WERE EXPENDED LAST YEAR.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BUT IF THERE'S NOTHING ELSE I
THINK WE'LL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. I COULD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MY NAME IS MARCELLA
RUIZ AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF EQUITY AND ISSUE
NUMBER TWO IS RELATED. TO FOR A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS BCPS
FOR THE OFFICE OF EQUITY A
PRISON ON THREE OF THEM. AND
THEN- PASS IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AS BRANCH CHIEF AND I
CAME AWAY IT'S FOR THE FOURTH
WHICH IS RELATED TO THE
IMMIGRATION WORK. SO OUR FIRST
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL IS FOR OUR
LANGUAGE SERVICES UNIT WHICH-
WE ARE SEEKING FOR POSITIONS
ONE AS A SOMEONE AND THREE
EIGHT GPAS. TO EXPAND OUR IN
HOUSE CAPACITY FOR LANGUAGE
ACCESS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS. AS YOU ARE AWARE
CDSS PROGRAMS ARE SUBJECT
MULTIPLE FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS
THAT REQUIRE A DOCUMENT
TRANSLATION SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THE POPULATIONS WE
SERVE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION THAT WE PROVIDE.
CURRENTLY OUR STAFFING IS SEVEN
POSITIONS ONE S. ASSIGNMENT SIX
EIGHT GPAS. AND WITH THAT WE
WILL PROBABLY WERE ABLE TO
PRODUCE- HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PRODUCE BETWEEN TEN THOUSAND
AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND PAGES OF
TRANSLATION PER YEAR ALL JUST
NOTE THAT IS TWICE AS MANY AS
WE TRANSLATED FIVE YEARS AGO.
AS YOU ARE AWARE OUR DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN EXPANDING AND WITH
PROGRAM EXPANSION AND
REORGANIZATION SUCH AS THE
TRANSITION OF THAT. CITY
PROGRAMS WE WILL ALSO NEED TO
EXPAND OUR RESOURCES TO ENSURE
LANGUAGE ACCESS SO THE ADDITION
OF THESE FOR REQUESTED. STAFF
TRANSLATORS WILL ALLOW CDSS TO
COVER MORE LANGUAGES IN HOUSE
AND TO ADDRESS THE INCREASED
VOLUME THAT THAT WE EXPECT AN
INVITE ONLY TO ENSURE THE
QUALITY CONTROL THAT IS OFTEN
SUCH A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
LANGUAGE. AS THE NEXT PROPOSAL
IS RELATED TO EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY- SIMILARLY TO THE
LAST PROPOSAL I JUST SPOKE
ABOUT GIVEN THE GROWTH IN THE
DEPARTMENT WE ALSO SEE AN
INCREASE NEED- TO STAFF UP IN
R. E. O. OR EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY. OFFICE WHICH IS
CURRENTLY STAFFED BY BY BY FIVE
STAFF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVESTIGATING- ALMOST TWICE AS
MANY COMPLAINTS AS WE SAW FIVE
FIVE YEARS AGO- WE ARE SEEKING
TO ADDITIONAL HEPA POSITIONS IN
ORDER TO LOWER THE RATIOS OF
THE NUMBER OF CASES PER STAFF
PERSON. AND THEREBY ENSURE THAT
CASES ARE RESOLVED IN A TIMELY
IN A TIMELY MANNER ULTIMATELY
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
RIGHTS OF ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES
AND OUR AND THE IN THE
POPULATION THAT WE SERVE. OUR
ARE ARE PROTECTED AND THAT
INVESTIGATIONS ARE TIMELY AND
ALSO WE WANT TO REDUCE- COSTLY
LITIGATION THAT CAN RESULT FROM
THE LAYS IN THE PROCESS. THE
THIRD PROPOSAL IS RELATED TO
OUR OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS- A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO WE WERE
AUTHORIZED TO FUNDS THREE HEPA
POSITIONS THAT SERVE IN THE
CAPACITY OF IF THEY EAT ECWA
FIELD LIAISON- THOSE POSITIONS
ARE GOING TO SUNSET AND SO WE
ARE ASKING FOR IT TO MAKE THOSE
THREE POSITIONS PER MINUTE. AT
AS YOU KNOW THE INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT WAS PASSED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND
RECOGNITION THAT AMERICAN
INDIAN CHILDREN. ARE WERE BEING
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOMES. ADAM
HIGHER RATE THAN NON NATIVE
CHILDREN CALIFORNIA HAS
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF A
QUAD HAS CODIFIED IN OUR OWN IN
OUR OWN STATUTES IN THE MAIN-
THE MAIN GOAL IS HERE TO ADD TO
PREVENT THE BREAK UP OF THE
INDIAN FAMILY AND TO PROVE
OUTCOMES FOR AMERICAN INDIAN
CHILDREN. THE THREE O'CLOCK
POSITIONS ARE REALLY CRITICAL
TO THAT TASK THEY COULDN'T ACT.
COUNTIES AND TRIBES WITH
RESOURCES THEY HELP BUILD THE
CAPACITY OF OUR OF OUR COUNTIES
ARE ENFORCING OUR CHILD
WELFARE- THAT ARE MANAGING AND
MEASURING OUR CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS- CONFORMITY AND COMPLIANCE
WITH WHAT IMPLEMENTATION THE
ENSURE THAT THERE IS THE RIGHT
LEVEL OF INQUIRY AN ACTIVE
EFFORTS MADE TO MAINTAIN AND TO
UNITE INDIAN CHILDREN. IN THEIR
HOMES OR WITH THEIR FAMILY AND-
WITH WITHIN THEIR TIBES- WE
REALLY SEE THIS IS A CRITICAL
CRITICAL EQUITY ISSUE GIVEN
THAT IN SOME COUNTIES THE
CASELOADS OF AMERICAN. A NATIVE
AMERICAN CHILDREN IN IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM MARK 40%
OF THE ENTIRE HE SLID THIS
COMPUTER TO A POPULATION SIZE
OF JUST UNDER 2% FOR IT FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE OF NATIVE.
AMERICAN OR A MINUTE AMERICAN
INDIAN POPULATIONS SO WE FEEL
LIKE THESE POSITIONS WOULD BE
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT WE SEE
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR AMERICAN
INDIAN CHILDREN. AND WITH THAT
I WILL HAND IT BACK OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AND I KEEP A WHAT'S
FOR THE FOURTH ITEM UNDER THE
OFFICE. OF EQUITY BCPS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SO B. C. THAT
WE'RE REQUEST FOR. IMMIGRATION
SERVICES RAPID RESPONSE UNIT IS
TO ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAM ANALYST HEPA. TO MEET
IMMIGRANT NEEDS GIVEN THE
ONGOING EMERGENCY TRACE
INSTANCES THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND THE BORDER
SITUATION IN RECENT WILDFIRES.
ARE CSS IMMIGRATION SERVICES
CREATED THE RAPID RESPONSE UNIT
IN FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT DISASTER ASSISTANCE-
PRIMARILY FOR UNDOCUMENTED
RESIDENTS WHO DO NOT QUALIFY
FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED SERVICES.
CURRENTLY THIS UNIT HAS TO
LIMITED TERM STOCK POSITIONS
ONE MANAGER SPECIALIST AND ONE
ANALYST. USED TO ADDITIONAL
STAFF WOULD ALLOW THE RAPID
RESPONSE UNIT TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DESIGN IMPLEMENT
AND MONITOR SEVERAL RESPONSE
INITIATIVES AT ONCE WITHOUT
HAVING TO TEMPORARILY BORROW
STAFF. FROM OUR OTHER
IMMIGRATION PROGRAMS THEMSELVES
CARRY A SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYTHING FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I SEE NOTHING- L. A.
O. S. C. YOUR HANDS UP. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE'VE REVIEWED THE
PROPOSALS- AND HAVE NO
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THE DIFFERENT.
PROPITIATE THE PROPOSAL SET UP
PARTICULARLY AS CHAIR OF THE
API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS-
LANGUAGE ACCESS TO HUGE BARRIER
TO PEOPLE GETTING SERVICES AND-
PREACH AND THE FACT THAT WE
WERE FALLING BEHIND THIS WAS
CONCERNING CELL FREESHEET THAT
WE'RE GONNA MAKE INVESTMENT TO
ENSURE PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO BUDGET
FOR. THIS COMING YEAR THROUGH-
IMPROVE TRANSLATION THAT THAT
THE FARM SOCIAL SERVICES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY-
SO LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE FLEXIBILITY AN
ALLOCATION OF REFUGEE SUPPORT
SERVICE FUND. IF I MAY- I THINK
THERE WAS AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION IN ISSUE NUMBER TWO
ABOUT. ELEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
THE COLLEGE ALL SHE- GO AHEAD.
I JUST LIKE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
UPDATE ON THAT FINDING THAT THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN APPROPRIATE FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO CREATE THE FIRST
STATE FUNDED IMMIGRATION LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP THE IMMIGRATION
LEGAL FELLOWSHIP AIMS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF REMOVAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS IN THE
CAPACITY OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
RELIABLE DEFENSE SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST AND
CENTRAL VALLEY REGION'S REMOVAL
DEFENSE IS A HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
AREA OF THE LAW THAT HAS BEEN
CONSTANTLY CHANGING AND
BECOMING INCREASINGLY COMPLEX
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
CALIFORNIA'S POOL OF EXPERIENCE
FOR MOBILE DEFENSE ATTORNEYS IT
IS SMALL COMPARED TO THE DEMAND
FOR SERVICES AND WORLD REGIONS
OFTEN HAVE NO AVAILABLE
QUALIFIED ATTORNEYS LEAVING
THESE POPULATIONS VULNERABLE TO
FRAUD AND RECEIVING SUBPAR
IMMIGRATIONLEGAL SERVICES- THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
IDENTIFY THE NEEDS BEST
PRACTICES AND DESIGN THE
TRAINING PROGRAM. AND SERVICE
DELIVERY MARK. WHAT WE'RE
FINDING TEN IN. THEFOLLOWS
WERE BEING HOST AT SEVEN
NONPROFIT FOR TWO YEARS TO
RECEIVE INTENSIVE REMOVAL
DEFENSE TRAINING AND MENTORING
AS WELL AS- PRACTICAL
EXPERIENCE SERVING WORLD.
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES- WE
SELECTED ONE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION TO WRITE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL TRAINING AND
OVERSEE THE THREE OTHER
PARTNERS WILL BE PROVIDING THE
RECRUITMENT MENTORSHIP AND
SUPPORTING THE CAPACITY OF THE
HOST NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
WE EXPECT THIS INVESTMENT WILL
INCREASE BOTH THE NUMBER OF
EXPERIENCE FOR MOBILE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS PROVIDING SERVICES ON
THE CENTRAL COAST AND CENTRAL
VALLEY. AS WELL AS THE CAPACITY
OF THE HOST ORGANIZATIONS TO
ESTABLISH AN ONGOING REMOVAL
DEFENSE PRACTICE WITHIN THEIR
OWN ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH AND THEN WE PLANET
HAS HAVE WE STARTED GET OR
WE'RE JUST BEGINNING THAT
CORRECT. YES BUT IT'S JUST JUST
STARTING OUT WITH SELECT
PROPOSAL EVEN PLACE WITH THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT. ANYTHING
ELSE ON THIS. ALL RIGHT THEN
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT. ISSUE
FLEXIBILITY AS A TWO YES LET ME
AS WELL- THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TITLE FLEXIBILITY IN
THE ALLOCATION OF REFUGEE
SUPPORT SERVICES TO PROVIDE THE
CITY SAYS THE FLEXIBILITY
NEEDED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
FEDERALLY FUNDED REFUGEE
POPULATIONS WHEN COUNTY SAN ARE
UNABLE TO DO SO. THE SPECIFIC
REQUEST SYSTEM AND WALDRON
SITUATIONS CODE SECTION
THIRTEEN TWO SEVEN SIX TO
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT WITH THE
DISCRETION TO RE ALLOCATE
DECLINED OR RETURNED FUNDING
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
OFFICE OF REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT
ELIGIBLE POPULATIONS NOT JUST
NOT JUST ARRIVAL DATA. IS
BACKGROUND THE DEPARTMENT
OVERSEAS CALIFORNIA'S REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS
FUNDED BY THE FEDERAL OFFICE OF
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT THROUGH
OUR REFUGEE PROGRAMS BUREAU
HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT THE
BUREAU IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING AND COORDINATING THE
DELIVERY OF BENEFITS AND
SERVICES TO THE REFUGEE
POPULATIONS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COUNTIES AND LOCAL REFUGEE
SERVICE PROVIDERS. EVERY YEAR
THE FEDERAL OFFICE OF REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT ALLOCATES A
SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF REFUGEE
SUPPORT SERVICES FUNDING TO
CALIFORNIA BASED ON THE
PROJECTED NUMBER OF REFUGEE
CLAIMANTS ARRIVING TO THE STATE
PAYMENTS TO THE STATES ARE MADE
CORD PAVEMENTS TO THE STATE ARE
MADE QUARTERLY LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED A BASE
AMOUNT OF FIFTEEN MILLION
700-252-0090 DOLLARS IN REFUGEE
SUPPORT SERVICES FUNDING AND
ANOTHER TWO MILLION- FOR
CERTAIN SET ASIDE PROGRAMS
TARGETING STUDENTS ELDERLY AND
YOUTH MENTORING. FOR A TOTAL OF.
SEVENTEEN NINE HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO. THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE BASE
WHERE SUPPORT SERVICES FUNDING
BE USED TO. A OF SUPPORTS.
INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT AND
WORKFORCE SKILL BUILDING
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ACQUISITION
AND CHILD CARE SUPPORT SIMILAR
TO THE SUPPORT SERVICES OFFERED
TO OUR STATE CAO WORKS PROGRAM.
IN CALIFORNIA REFUGEE SUPPORT
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED BY EIGHT
COUNTIES WITH LARGE REFUGEE
POPULATIONS THAT WE CALL
IMPACTED COUNTIES WILL RECEIVE
ALLOCATIONS BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF REFUGEE ARRIVALS NOT SILENCE
IN THEIR COUNTIES. UNDER
CURRENT STATUTE ONLY REFUGEE
IMPACTED COUNTIES ARE ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE REFUGEE SUPPORT
SERVICES. BASEDON THIS
CRITERIA THE FOLLOWING EIGHT
COUNTIES RECEIVED THE FUNDING
ALAMEDA LOS ANGELES ORANGE
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO SANTA CLARA AND
STANISLAUS. 95% OF THE STATE'S
REFUGEES RESETTLE IN ONE OF
THOSE IMPACTED COUNTIES.
ELIGIBLE COUNTIES ARE NOT
OBLIGATED TO ACCEPT THE
FINDINGS. CURRENTLY OUR WEEK
SECTION THIRTEEN TO SEVEN SIX
SPECIFIES HOW THAT FUNDING
ALLOCATION IS MADE BASED ON THE
POPULATION WITHOUT DISCRETION
OR FLEXIBILITY AFFORDED FOR
SITUATIONS WHERE THE COUNTY IS
UNABLE TO PROVIDE TARGETED
SERVICES FOR SPECIFIC
POPULATION. WITHIN A GIVEN TIME
FRAME. THIS WEEK SECTION
REQUIRE CSS TO DISTRIBUTE ALL
RECORD YOUR SUPPORT SERVICES
FUNDING INCLUDING THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION FROM O. R. R. AND
ANY DECLINED OR RETURNED FUNDS
PROPORTIONALLY TO ALL EIGHT
REFUGEE IMPACTED COUNTIES. IF A
COUNTY DECLINED TO RETURNS
FINDING THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO USES
FUNDING FOR OTHER COUNTIES WITH
HIGHER NEEDS. THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WOULD GIVE CSS THE
AUTHORITY AND THE DISCRETION TO
ALLOCATE DECLINED TO RETURN
REFUGEE SUPPORT SERVICES
FINDING. AND SUPPLEMENTAL OR
TARGETED FUNDING FROM THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH A
RESETTLEMENT TO OTHER SERVICE
SERVICE AREAS AS NEEDED. THE
REASON- OUR OUR REFUGEE SUPPORT
SERVICES SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
FOR KOBE NINETEEN RELATED
SUPPORT IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THE NEED FOR THIS WORKS
ABILITY- ARE PROVIDED
CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENTAL
ALLOCATION OF ABOUT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT REFUGEES IN
NEED OF ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
FOR HOUSING OR OTHER BUT BASIC
NEEDS DURING COVERT NINETEEN.
DURING THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. PER THE STATUTE
CALIFORNIA WAS REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE A PROPORTIONAL
ALLOCATION THE STATE WAS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE PROVIDE A
PROPORTIONAL ALLOCATION TO EACH
OF THE IMPACTED COUNTY. WITHOUT
REGARD TO THE COUNTY'S ABILITY
TO STAND UP SERVICES QUICKLY OR
THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THE
POPULATION. THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WOULD PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FLEXIBILITY
NEEDED TO USE RETURNED- ON USE
FUNDS TO TARGET IMMEDIATE.
NEEDS OF THE REFUGEE POPULATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE THING
FROM THE PART OF FINANCE I DO
NOT SEE YOUR HAND UP. ANYTHING
FROM THE L. A. O. I SEE YOU
SHAKING YOUR HEAD AND I WILL
TAKE THAT AS A NOT HAND UP. CAN
YOU CAN YOU TELL ME A LITTLE
ABOUT WHY A COUNTY WOULD. WOULD
DECLINE OR RETURN FUNDING. YES%
SOME SOME COUNTIES JUST DON'T
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY IN THEIR
CONTRACTS TO AND THAT REQUESTED
SERVICE PROVIDERS CHANGE THOSE
TO DELIVER TO IT TO CHANGE THE
SCOPE OF SERVICES QUICKLY.
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T HAVE A
KIND OF THAT CONTRACT
FLEXIBILITY AND OR THE
SPECIALIZED SERVICE PROVIDERS
IN THEIR AREA TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE THE SPECIFIC POPULATION
NEEDED. SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
IF. OUR OUR WORD TO REQUEST TO
TURN COUNTY PROVIDE SERVICES TO
HAITIAN ARRIVALS AND THEY DON'T
HAVE A SERVICE PROVIDER TO DO
THAT THEY THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO STAND THAT UP QUICKLY ON
THEIR OWN. OKAY IN BEEN. MY OWN
EDUCATION IF SOMEBODY SO. SO I
LIVE IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IS COVERED
STANISLAUS COUNTY IS COVERED
THAT'S RIGHT IN BETWEEN. THOSE
TWO IF SOMEONE'S IN LOVE
SOMEONE CAN COME NEEDS HELP. IS
THERE ARE THERE. M. O. EIGHT M.
O. USE IN PLACE WITH. OTHER
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES OR IS
IT JUST PEOPLE WHO RESIDE IN
THOSE COUNTIES ARE ELIGIBLE.
THE FEDERAL ARE ARE FINDING
ONLY FLOW THROUGH THOSE EIGHT
IMPACTED COUNTIES HOWEVER THERE
ARE MANY IMMIGRANT SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THESE REFUGEES IT'S JUST NOT
USING THE- ARE FEDERALLY FUNDED
ALLOCATION. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOCTRINE. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE ACTUALLY THIS
PRESS QUICK QUESTION FOR L. A.
L. IS- I GET THE DESIRE FOR
FLEXIBILITY- DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS IN TERMS OF. OVERSIGHT
THAT WE SHOULD BE X. ASKING
FOR- FOR AN EXCHANGE FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY. HI THIS IS RYAN
ANDERSON THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY INCOME. SPECIFIC CONCERNS
OR COMMENTS WITH REGARDS TO
THAT AT THIS TIME BUT WHEN
CONTINUING. TO LOOK AT ALL
THESE PROPOSAL SO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU. WE HAVE SPECIFIC
CONCERNS NINE APPRECIATE THAT I
MEAN THAT THAT THAT'S ONLY
UNDERSTAND THE PRESENTATION AND
TO THEM AND- WHY THEY WANT
FLEXIBILITY EXCELLENT BE SURE
THAT WE- SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT OVER- THE FLEXIBILITY
SO THAT- THAT ULTIMATELY THAT
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY FOR. HOW
HOW FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY SPENT
THANK YOU. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
FLEXIBILITY WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
THINK WILL MOVE NOW ON TO
UNLESS I'M MISSING SOMETHING
AGAIN DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES ISSUE NUMBER FOR CHILD
WELFARE PANDEMIC RESPONSE
PROPOSALS. GREAT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ASSASSIN AND
SENATOR DOCTOR DOCTOR PAN- FOR-
GIVE ME A CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH
YOU ABOUT A HANDFUL OF
IMPORTANT ITEMS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL-
ITEMS FOR IS THE CITY TO THE
CHILD WELFARE PANDEMIC RESPONSE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. DO
YOU NEED SOME VERY CRITICAL
NEEDS- I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
LARGELY THE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
IS INTENDED TO REPLICATE. WHAT
HAPPENED WHAT THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WERE MADE IN THE SPRING-
SOME OF THOSE WERE DISCUSSED AT
A RECENT ARE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES OUR PROBATE- COMMITTEE
MEETING. BACK. IN THE FALL. AND
PROPOSALS ALSO INCLUDE- THE
MOST PART THE CURRENT. I
REQUEST AND A BUDGET RIGHT YOUR
REQUEST. SHOULD NOTE ALSO THAT
FIGURES FOR ON PAGE SIXTEEN OF
THE AGENDA AS- LAYS OUT THAT
THE FUNDING REQUEST VERY
SPECIFICALLY AND SO. AS A
RESULT I WON'T DIE NECESSARILY
GET INTO ALL THAT THAT THAT
DOLLARS AND CENTS OF EACH OF
THE PROPOSALS BUT WOULD LIKE
TO. BRIEFLY DESCRIBE TO YOU THE
IMPORTANCE OF. EACH ONE AND SO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT EITHER
PROPOSALS ARE KIND OF ALL A
BUNDLED UP ON THE ON THE CHART.
RESPECT TO SUPPORT FOR OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WERE FORMERLY
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT WERE IN OUR
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
THAT WOULD HAVE LOST
ELIGIBILITY AT AGE. TWENTY ONE
THE DISEASE THIS PROPOSAL IS.
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE- THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE. HAS
RESORCES AND SUPPORT- DURING
THE DURING THE PANDEMIC IN SO
THAT THE PROPOSAL IS TO PROVIDE
SOME FINANCIAL SUPPORT SH-
EQUIVALENT TO WHAT THEY WOULD
HAVE RECEIVED IN A FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT. AND SOME BASIC CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES FROM. FROM
THE FROM THE COUNTY. WITH
RESPECT TO ASSISTANCE FOR
EMERGENCY CARE GIVERS THIS THIS
PROPOSAL IS VERY POOR PROPOSAL
ACKNOWLEDGES THE FACT THAT HAS-
FAMILIES ARE TRYING TO GET
APPROVED TO BECOME RESOURCE
FAMILIES THROUGH THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS.
JACOBSON AND ISSUES RELATED TO.
THE PANDEMIC THAT HAD MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO GO
THROUGH THIS THE SYSTEM AS
DESIGNED AS SMOOTHLY AS
DESIGNED AND THEREFORE- THIS IS
THIS PROPOSAL IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS WHO STEP UP TO- TO
ACCEPT A- MEMBER OF THEIR
FAMILY INTO THEIR THEIR CHAIR.
AS A RESULT OF AN EMERGENCY
THAT'S RELATED TO- THAT THAT
THE CHILD'S PARENTS AND SO THIS
PROPOSAL PER. FUNDS FUNDS THE
EMERGENCY- UP US PROVIDES
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE TO THE
CARE GIVERS WELL THEY ARE
MAKING THEIR WAY THROUGH THAT
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS. WITH RESPECT TO
SUPPORT FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES
AGAIN THIS PROPOSAL SPEAKS TO
THE ABILITY AND THE NEED TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- THAT FOR FAMILIES
FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES FOSTER
PARENTS AND AT THE LIKE THAT
ARE. WHO IS YOUR WHO WHOSE
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE ARE ARE
GRAPPLING WITH CODE RELATED
ISSUES AND SO THIS- THIS
PROPOSAL ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE-
THROUGH OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES.
A NUMBER OF- OF FLEXIBLE
OPTIONS PROVIDE TO PROVIDE A
DISH RESOURCE TO DEAL WITH- THE
ISSUES ARE SO OFTEN ASSOCIATED
WITH QUARANTINE AND ISOLATION.
THERE'S A THERE'S A REQUEST FOR
FUNDING FOR STATE ADMINISTERED
CONTRACTS AS WELL AND SIMILARLY
AS AS WE DID IN THE SPRING WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE IS TO
CONTINUE SOME OF THE CONTRACTS
THAT SUPPORT. FAMILIES IN
DIFFERENT WAYS SPECIFICALLY
THERE IS A REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE- THE WARM WINDS
THAT WE THAT WE STOOD UP SOME
TIME AGO- THERE'S FUNDING FOR-
SOME CONTRACTS WE USED TO.
DIRECTLY COMMUNICATE WITH WITH
CARE GIVERS AROUND THEIR THEIR
NEEDS- THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS
THIS ALSO ALLOWS US TO WORK
WITH THEM IN A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT TECHNOLOGY IN THE HANDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM
FOR OR I DISTANCE LEARNING AND
FOR TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
TELEHEALTH AND OTHER OTHER
SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES. THE
REQUESTED THIS TO. US ACCORDING
AT RISK FAMILIES THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER SO IF YOU MAY RECALL
FROM THE THIS SPRING- THERE IS
A HUNDRED OVER A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND FAMILIES
SERVED WITH THAT YOU KNOW
DIRECTLY TO SERVICES AND SOME.
REFERRALS TO STATE AND FEDERAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE RELATED TO
THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE- THROUGH
OUR FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
THAT THAT THAT FUNDING- WAS ONE
WAS A TIME LIMITED WE'RE
SUGGESTING THAT GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THAT WE-
CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
GOODS AND SERVICES THROUGH THAT
THE NETWORK OF FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS ARE BOTH IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
WE ALSO ARE SO DOES THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES FINDING
IT- REQUEST FOR FUNDING TO
SUPPORT DIRECTLY SUPPORT ASK AT
RISK FAMILIES KNOWN TO THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM TO AVOID
THEIR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE COMING
INTO FOSTER CARE. AND SO- THIS
IS THIS IS A CURRENT YEAR ONLY
PROPOSAL IN THE- IN THE- IN THE
BUDGET. SIMILAR TO. THE
ACTIVITIES WEEK THAT TOOK PLACE
IN THE SPRING WE'RE SUGGESTING
THAT WE PROVIDE A DIRECT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO- TO
FAMILIES. THROUGH THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE USE OF- OUR TO
MEDIUM OF A PREPAID CARDS AND
SO THIS WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THOSE
FAMILIES TO ADDRESS NEEDS THAT-
MAY HAVE RESULTED AS A RESULT
OF. LOSING THEIR JOB OR OTHER-
OTHER FINANCIAL PRESSURES THAT
THEY MAY. THEY MAY SEE. SO
THAT'S THE OVERVIEW OF THE- OF
THE VARIOUS- OF PROPOSALS THAT
ARE KIND OF BUNDLED UP INTO
INTO THE CHART ON- ON PAGE
SIXTEEN. THE NEXT QUESTION IN
THE AGENDA SPEAKS TO- ONE OF
THE FUNDING- THAT WE HADN'T HAD
LAST YEAR FOR SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES. QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY ASKS. YES- IF
COUNTY CONTINUED. TO DO THOSE
WORK THAT WORK AND SO-HOW IS
IT FUNDED. GIVEN THE LIMITED
THAT THOUGH THE LITTLE THE ONE
TIME NATURE OF THE LIMITED THE
TIME SHOP THE TIME THAT THE
TIME LIMITED NATURE OF THE
FUNDING AT THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
THE SPRING OF MOST OF THOSE
MOST OF THE PROGRAMS WERE
ACTUALLY ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT WITH SUBSTANTIAL
SUPPORT- THROUGH A COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE. THE COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE WORKERS FORCED. THESE
THESE. THESE PROGRAMS DID- DO
YOU SEE SAID DAD WILL WIN THE
FUNDING LAST DAY AT WORK AS
LONG AS THE FUNDING TERM WAS
TERMINATED OR AS THE FUNDING
RAN OUT OF BASED ON IT'S TIME
LIMITED NATURE THAT SAID THERE
WAS A COUPLE OF A COUPLE OF
ITEMS THAT DID CONTINUE ONE WAS
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE
DEPARTMENT WAS ABLE TO
REPURPOSE SOME RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE WARM
WIND THAT. THAT CREEK THAT
PROVIDED SUPPORT TO FAMILIES IN
THE COMMUNITY AND DIRECTLY
RECALL REFERRED THEM TO OTHER
RESOURCES INCLUDING- THAT
CONTRACT ALSO INCLUDED DIRECT-
SUPPORT GROUPS FOR A NUMBER OF
FAMILIES- DURING THAT TIME
PERIOD IN THE SPRING THAT HAS
CONTINUED ON THE OTHER THE
OTHER ISSUES THE OTHER ITEM
THAT HAS CONTINUED WITHOUT WAS
KING IT IS CONTINUING AS WE
SPEAK WAS AS A RESULT OF THE
BUDGET ACTIVE- LAST YEAR SO
THAT WE ARE. CONTINUING. TO
SUPPORT- THE R. FINANCIAL
SOMETIME NEED TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT WOULD HAVE A OUT OF
OUR- FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
CHINESE ARE FUNDED ALSO TO
PROVIDE SOME CASE MANAGEMENT
TO. TO THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE. BY
MY COLLEAGUE JUSTIN FREITAS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WILL. TAKE ON QUESTION THREE
SECTION THANK YOU THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES JUST A TRACE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
BELIEVE THE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE CURRENT YEAR FUNDING AND
WHAT MECHANISM THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS INTENDING TO
USE TO GET THOSE RESOURCES OUT
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON NON
IDENTIFYING AN APPROPRIATE-
VESSEL OR METHOD TO GET THOSE
AYE RESOURCES OUT AND AS- WE
DETERMINE WHAT WILL REACH OUT
AND COMMUNICATE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH. WHICH CAPITAL
GO. I WOULD HOPE SO OKAY. THE
DENTAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OKAY HELLO. PLEASE THE
SHORT GOOD AFTERNOON- ANGELA
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY PARTICULAR CONCERNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
ACTIONS FOR COVERT RESPONSE
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE AS YOU
HEARD THESE PROPOSALS- WOULD
ALL BE CONTINUING OR OR RE
LAUNCHING ACTIVITIES THAT
HAPPENED EARLIER IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND THAT SIR VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WITHIN
THE CHILD WELFARE SSTEM.
RATHER OUR QUESTIONS ARE
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS AND OUR QUESTIONS
REFLECT- THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
ALSO INCLUDED IN YOUR AGENDA SO
SPECIFICALLY- IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE PROPOSALS IN
THE CURRENT YEAR WHAT WOULD BE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
MECHANISM TO DO SO I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
TO UNDERSTAND THAT MECHANISM
AND- BE IN CONTACT WITH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- AND JUST.
ONE OTHER QUESTION WE HAVE IS-
IF THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER ANY ADDITIONAL
PANDEMIC SUPPORT NEEDS WITHIN
CHILD WELFARE BEYOND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED A
FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER- FUNDING SOME
DIRECT SUPPORT FOR ALL RESOURCE
FAMILIES. AND A SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. THANK
pI'D I'D SAY I AGREE I THINK
THAT THERE COULD HAVE PLANS BUT
WE NEED TO DETAILS OF THE PLANS
AND HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA-
EXECUTE THEM- IT AND AS FAR AS-
IT I UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'RE
NOT PLAN. ON DOING- MORE DIRECT
PAYMENTS DEFEND AT RISK OF
FOSTER CARE IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND CAN WE GET SOME
DATE ON ON HOW WAS IT AFFECTED
IT HELP FAMILIES AND BECAUSE
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING WE WANT
TO CONTINUE ON. EVEN FURTHER
OUT. WITH RESPECT TO YOUR LAST
QUESTION AGAIN GREG ROSE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. WE DID A SERVICE
SERVE A LITTLE OVER TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND FAMILIES LAST YEAR IN
IN IN THE SPRING WITH THAT WITH
THAT PREPAID CARDS. AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY WELCOME. INTERESTED
IN PROVIDING A U. N. STAFF WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION RELATIVE
TO ITS EFFECTIVENESS IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE DIRECT CASH.
PAYMENTS TO HOUSEHOLDS-
DIRECTLY AFFECTED THAT THEIR
RETURN TO. THE CHILD SAFETY
SAFETY AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT
YOUNG PERSON WOULD HAVE ENDED
UP IN FOSTER CARE OR NOT THERE
ARE MANY OTHER CONTRIBUTING
FACTORS BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION THAT-
THAT WE DO HAVE. TO STAFF.
AFTER THE HEARING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND HOW ABOUT FOR A
FOSTER FOSTER CHILDREN SELVES
AGING OUT OF THE SYSTEM. BUT WE
PLAN ON A LONGER BREAK BUT
ASIDE TWENTY FOR THAT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS BOTH THE
ASK IS BOTH THE CURRENT YEAR
AND A BUDGET YEAR PROPOSAL
THROUGH THE END OF THE CALENDAR
YEAR. DISCOUNTING OKAY SAID
SOMETHING WILL COME BACK TO
DOCTOR. THANK YOU- SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS THAT BECAUSE WE
ARE BUDGET IS ACTUALLY FOR JULY
THROUGH JUNE- MORE BUDGETING
FUNDS THROUGH THE MID MIDDLE OF
THAT FISCAL YEAR WHAT IS THE
PLAN FOR THE OTHER HALF OF THAT
FISCAL YEAR IS A JUST A CLIFF
STUFF HAPPENS OR IS THE
ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO COME
BACK TO US OR IS IT GONNA BE
ROOM. NAY REVISED WE LOOKING AT
SOME SORT OF THING- SO I'M JUST
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER ON JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHEN WE
ARE STILL NURSE SAME FISCAL
YEAR BUT WE HAVE NOTHING
BUDGETED FOR BEYOND THAT- IS
THAT SOMETHING YOU PLAN TO COME
BACK TO US LATER FOR THE
BUDGET. OR. JUSTIN REYES
PROVIDE AT THIS TIME. WHAT
WHAT'S INCLUDED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS PLAN DOES HE SAID FOR
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES THROUGH
JANUARY OF- TWENTY THREE TWO TO
THE EXTENT OF ANYTHING REALLY
CHANGED WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT AND REVERSION BACK
THIS TIME- NOTHING CLOSE BEYOND
WHAT'S INCLUDED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. OKAY SO I HOPE THAT
WILL AT LEAST HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN AND THAT TRANSITION
WHICH THAT'S MIDWAY THROUGH OUR
FISCAL YEAR SO WE WON'T HAVE SO
WITH THE- WE DID SOMETHING FOR
THE NEXT. BUDGET THAT'S A SIX
MONTH GAP SO. THE DAILY TO HAVE
SOME. MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THE PLAN IS FOR THAT. THAT
THAT PERIOD OF TIME IS IT THERE
WE JUST OF THE SAYING THAT. THE
END OF THE CALENDAR YEAR JUST
CUT OFF AND- THEY'LL BE FINE OR
IS THERE SOME SORT OF
ASSESSMENT IS GOING TO BE DONE
OR SOME. SOME NATURE. BUT MOST
OF THOSE THINGS REQUIRE
RESOURCES SELL WIDE SIDE DECKS
THE HOPEFULLY IN YOUR NEXT
PROPOSAL- THERE'S GOING TO BE
SOME WAY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION ABOUT. IT IS JUST
LITERALLY A PROPOSAL IS THAT ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. EVEN JUST DANCE.
OKAY WE EXPECT A RESPONSE UNDER
BROWN OR YOU JUST WANNA MAKE
THE WELL I GUESS I GUESS I
EXPECT THE RESPONSE AND THAT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE RIGHT NOW
BUT- HOPEFULLY WHEN THIS WHEN
WE FINALLY ACTUALLY VOTE ON
THINGS- WE WILL HAVE A RESPONSE
TO THAT. EVEN GOOD TO HAVE A
RESPONSE BEFORE WE VOTE. OKAY
TO MOVING ON INTO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE INCREASE STAFFING. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN
GREG GROSS FROM THE FROM THE
APARTMENT HERE TO SPEAK WITH
YOU ABOUT- FOR- BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS WITH OR THE
DEPARTMENT- WITHIN THE DIVISION
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILY
SERVICES. THE FIRST ONE IS THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES REVIEW QUALITY
ASSURANCE- TEAM. THIS IS A
REQUEST FOR A MANAGER IN JUNE
ANALYSTS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ARE THEY COUNTIES RELATIVE
TO THE FEDERALLY MANDATED CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES REVIEW
PROCESS THIS SEEK YOU I PROCESS
THAT THE FEDS HAVE PUT IN
PLACE. EACH ROUND YOU CAN A
LITTLE. MORE AT THE BAR IS
RAISED A BIT HIGHER AND THAT
THE STAKES ARE A BIT HIGHER AND
SO THESE- THESE THESE. THIS
GROUP OF PEOPLE WILL BE WOULD
BE ADDED TO OUR EXISTING TEAM
OF TWO UNITS OF PEOPLE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ASK THE
COUNTIES ON. SPECIFICALLY THERE
COUNTIES ASSESSMENTS THAT. THE
THAT DOWN THROUGH. AND OF THE-
AND THEIR SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT
PLANS. SO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THESE POSITIONS AND A
TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
THOUSAND. DOLLARS THE NEXT.
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT I
WANTED TO SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT
AS THE CHILDREN SERVICES POLICY
AND PROGRAM SUPPORT BCP- THIS
ONE YOU MAY. THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO THE DEPARTMENT. FOUR FOR IN
A LIMITED TERM FASHION TO-
STAND UP OUR- SEE SEE OUR UNION
OUR CONTINUUM OF CARE BRANCH
AND SO THESE RESOURCES ARE-
FROM THIS CROSS DIVISIONAL-
PROPOSAL THAT INCLUDES THAT MY
DIVISION AND SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL IS TO
CONTINUE WITH THE EVOLUTION OF
THE CCR WORK WHICH SPECIFICALLY
IN THIS THIS TIME. FOCUSES ON.
IMPLEMENT HIGH QUALITY TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE WITH THE AND THE
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS AND TO
CONTINUE TO USE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTIES AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ON PROVIDING HIGH
QUALITY. WRAPAROUND AND OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES TO
AVOID RESIDENTIAL PLACEMENT IN
ADDITION NEEDS RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO- TO IMPLEMENT OUR
FEDERAL. THE FEDERAL LAW THE
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACTS THE CARD FOR
WHICH IS THE CONGREGATE CARE
PIECE OF THE ACT SHOULD LEAD
THE THIS. THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES OVER FIFTY SIX
POSITION INCLUDES FIFTY SIX
POSITIONS FORTY OF THEM- ARE
ARE WE'RE ASKING FOR CONTINUED
FUNDING AND THERE ARE SIXTEEN
NEW POSITIONS IN THE IN THE MIX
TO DEAL WITH ALL OF THE
IMPORTANT CONGREGATE CARE
ISSUES- FACING US. AND. ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE FEDERAL LAW.
THE NEXT BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
THAT TO SPEAK YOU ABOUT IS- THE
RE OF THE FOR THE FOSTER CARE
OMBUDSPERSON- THIS REQUESTED IS
TO CONTINUE FINDING THAT- WAS
LIMITED TERM IN THE NATURE OF A
COUPLE OF MANAGERS AND A FEW
AND FOR- ANALYSTS STAFF. ARE
YOU MAY YOU MAY RECALL THAT-
THAT IN PREVIOUS YEARS THE- THE
ALMONDS OFFICE HAS INCREASED
HIGHER CALL VOLUME. UP BY ABOUT
31% AND THE NUMBER OF CASES
THAT IT MANAGES MONTHLY HAS
INCREASED BY ABOUT 64% SAID
PREVIOUSLY THESE RESOURCES WERE
PROVIDED TO ADDRESS THOSE OF
THOSE NUMBERS I WOULD SAY ALSO
THAT THE ARMBANDS OFFICE
CONTINUES TO SEE A GREAT DEAL.
OF CALLS OFTEN RELATED TO THAT.
THAT ATTENTION THAT MANY HAVE.
MAY DAY MAY GIVES TO- TO THAT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE STATE
CLICK SO STABLE I PREFER TO
THEM WHAT NURTURE HOMES AND-
WITH THE RECENT RELEASE OF THE
FOSTER CARE- BILL UPDATED
FOSTER YOUR BILL OF RIGHTS-
ADDITIONAL CALL VOLUME AND ASKS
FOR TRAINING ARE COMING IN SO
WITH- WITH THIS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AGAIN IS FOUR SIX
POSITIONS- ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE FINAL BCP THAT I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT TO YOU- IS- ARE
MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT OF
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES DATA
QUALITY FIRST. C. O. U. S. C.
M. S. CARES WHICH IS A LOT OF A
LOT OF- WHAT WORDS IN THE TITLE
REALLY WITH THIS WHEN DID WITH
THIS IS KEEP GETTING AT IS.
THAT OUR CURRENT CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. RECIEVES
WILLIAMS MILLION OF DATA ENTRY-
DATA ENTRIES AND DATA. BOTH
WALLACE AND QUANTITATIVE DATA
EACH YEAR. AS AS WE HAVE BECOME
AS YOU HAVE BECOME AND AS
OTHERS HAVE BECOME MUCH MORE.
INTERESTED IN DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING THE QUALITY OF
THE DATA OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO BE-
HE OF HIGH QUALITY IN ORDER TO
MAKE DECISIONS ARE INFORMED THE
BEST POSSIBLE WAY. ADDITIONALLY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
REQUIRED. ONGOING MONITORING OF
DATA QUALITY. WITH RESPECT TO A
NUMBER OF ITS FEDERAL REPORTS
ON OUT ON OUTCOMES ON FEDERAL
ELIGIBILITY WITH RESPECT TO
FOSTER CARE FUNDS AND A NUMBER
OF AUTHORIZATIONS FOR VARIOUS
EXPENDITURES WITHIN THE- THAT
WHAT. INFORMATION THAT'S WITHIN
THE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM- AND
SO BY GETTING THIS THIS REQUEST
IS- TO CONTINUE TO WORK THAT
ONE UNIT. HEADED BY A MANAGER
FOR ANALYSTS HAVE BEEN DOING-
TO IMPROVE OUR DATA QUALITY WE
SEE THIS IS ONGOING WORK AND
THEREFORE. THE NEW IS WE'RE
ASKING FOR NEED TO BE FROM
JEOPARDY TO OUR- THANK YOU.
THERE IS A QUESTION A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ALSO IF I COULD- AS A
SERVICE HE ADDED WITH THE WITH
THIS ISSUE IN THE IN THE
AGENDA- ONE OF WHICH IS ACCESS
TO SPEAK TO A RESOURCES THAT
WERE RECENTLY PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT BY THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE AS
PART OF OUR- WORK CHIU RETURNED
A YOUNG PEOPLE TO- TO.
CALIFORNIA THAT HAD BEEN IN.
HOW TO STATE RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS IN THE QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY ASKS HOW WILL THE
REQUESTED POSITIONS HELP IN
SERVING MONITORING THE ISSUE
THAT WATER DEPARTMENTS PLAN
SURE ISSUES ARE CARED FOR IN
THE FUTURE AND WOULD WE KNOW
TOO THAT- THE P. C. P. THAT I
DESCRIBED EARLIER THAT THAT THE
CHILDREN SERVICES POLICY AND
PROGRAM SUPPORT THE C. P. IS
THERE ARE SOME OF THE RESOURCES
THAT WE- ARE. WOULD BE NEEDED
TO CONTINUE THE WORK THAT WE
STARTED WITH THE OUT OF STATE-
HOME- REPATRIATION WORK.
SPECIFICALLY THE WORK THAT WE
DID WAS BUILT ON THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROCESS THAT THE-
CURRENCIES THE OUR BRANCH HAD
DEVELOPED AND REFINED TO OUR TO
SUPPORT. COUNTIES IN IN
LOCATING PLACEMENTS FOR YOUNG
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH COMPLEX NEEDS
AND IT WAS THAT PROCESS- THAT.
COMBINATION WITH SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT CONTRACT BINDING THE
HATCH THAT ALLOWED US TO BRING
BACK THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY OR
SO YOUNG PEOPLE TO CALIFORNIA-
WITH PLANS THAT WERE UNIQUELY
TAILORED TO THEIR NEEDS AND SO
SOME OF THESE RESOURCES FROM
THAT BCP WOULD. DO OUR TO THE
QUESTIONS YOU ASK CLEARLY WE
ARE OUR WORK AS SHE HAS IT IS
TRANSITIONING FROM BRINGING
YOUNG PEOPLE BACK TO CALIFORNIA
IN TWO. KEEPING THEIR- MEETING
THEIR NEEDS AND THE PLACEMENT
THERE OUR OR ADJUSTING THEIR
PLACEMENT TO MEET THEIR NEEDS
AND SO. THAT THE WORK THAT THE
CCR BRANCH HAS BEEN DOING WITH.
WITH THESE RESOURCES ALSO WILL.
MARQUISATE NEED IS NEEDED TO
CONTINUE THAT THE WORK FROM
TRANSITIONING TO SUPPORT OF
PLACEMENT PRESERVATION FOR
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE THE LAST
QUESTION IS WHAT WE IN THE WEST
APARTMENTS PLANNED TO ENSURE
THESE YOUTHS ARE CARED FOR IN
THE FUTURE OBVIOUSLY THERE IS-
THAT THAT. THERE IS THERE'S A
LOT TO ANALYZE IT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND SO WE'RE CONTINUING
TO ASSESS THE NEEDS AND THE
SERVICES FOR THIS POPULATION IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE WORK OUT
OF OUR IT HAS BEEN STARTED
THROUGH OUR WORK WITH. EIGHTY
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE THAT WAS
PASSED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WE
BY JANET SITES SOME ARE GAPS IN
OUR SERVICE ARRAY- AND WE WILL
CONTINUE THROUGH THAT PROCESS
AND THROUGH DILIGENT MONITORING
AND SUPPORT OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WERE RECENTLY RETURNED TO
CALIFORNIA. TO CONTINUE TO
REFINE OUR- OUR SERVICE ARRAY.
AND THE MANNER IN WHICH WE
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THIS
POPULATION. THE THIRD QUESTION
IN THIS SECTION HAS TO DO WITH
THE ON BUDGET AND HIS
RELATIONSHIP TO PLACEMENT
STABILITY. THROUGH THE PASSAGE-
YEAH I THINK THEY'RE OFTEN
THROUGH THE PASSAGE OF EIGHTY
TWO TWO FOUR SEVEN AND SO WITH
WITH RESPECT TO THE THIS
QUESTION AND- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT- YES I
THINK THAT'S I THINK I SAID
EARLIER THERE THERE HAS BEEN A
GREAT DEAL OF INTEREST FROM
MANY. ON PLACEMENT STABILITY
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS INCLUDE
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF-
RECENT BUDGET ACTIONS AND SOME
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS THAT THAT
THAT- FOCUSED ON THE CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF.
HAVING YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
STABILITY IN THEIR LIVES. THE
OFFICE OF THE AUTHOR OF THE
FOSTER CARE OMBUDSMAN WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT AT. THE TONE OF THIS
ENTITY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT-
HAS RECEIVED IN THE LAST. TWO
FISCAL YEAR IS AN INCREASE OF
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND 22% WHAT
OF COMPLAINTS RELATIVES TO.
FOSTER FOSTER CARE. PLACEMENT
STABILITY SOME OF THAT HAS TO
DO WITH THE CHANGE OF LAW FROM-
THE SO CALLED SEVEN DAY NOTICE
TO THE FOURTEEN DAY NOTICE AND
ALSO SOME OF THE LAW ALSO
REQUIRES A NUMBER. OF PLACEMENT
PRESERVATION STRATEGIES TO BE
IN PLACE PRIOR TO- UP. TO
PROVIDE A NOTICE THAT THE YOUNG
PERSON. NEEDS TO NEEDS A NEW
PLACE TO LIVE AND SO THE OFFICE
OFFICE HAS BEEN RECEIVING THOSE
CALLS HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE- WITH THE THAT THE COUNTIES
WHERE THAT THAT- WHERE THE
COMPLAINTS ORIGINATED IN. AND
THEY ARE- WORKING ALSO WITH
THAT PRIVATE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE OF A CHILD A FAMILY TEAMS.
ARE ARE OCCURRING AS AS
REQUIRED AND THAT A NUMBER OF-
STABILITY- PRACTICES HAVE BEEN
TRIED AND- IT BASS OF ANY
NOTICE AND SO THE FOSTER CARE
ASA FOSTER CARE OMBUDSMAN- WELL
IT'S DIFFICULT TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HOW
THE HOW. HAS ITS WORK DIRECTLY
RESULTED IN- IN PLAY IN THE GYM
CHANGE IN PLACEMENT STABILITY
CERTAINLY FOR THEIR CASES IN
WHICH THE FOSTER CARE
OMBUDSMAN'S OFFICE IS. IT IS
DIRECTLY. WORK FOCUSING ON WE
HAVE SEEN ANOTHER OF POSITIVE
PRESS- AND I THINK I'LL
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS WITH THANK
YOU THANK YOU MUCH AND I'M VERY
WHERE THEY WERE. ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES TO FROM SESSIONS BUT I
WOULD ASK IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS YES DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. LET'S FACE FARM
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS ON THOSE PROPOSALS
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE HELLO.
YES JUST REGARDING BE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS DESCRIBED TO
BE REVIEWED THOSE PROPOSALS AND
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WOULD JUST SAY- ACT. NO
LATER ARE THE USEFUL BROUGHT
BACK ARE THEY ALL IN ONE
FACILITY ARE THEY SPREAD OUT
ACROSS THE STATE AND THEN. AND
THEN MY QUESTION WOULD BE AND
THEN HOW ARE THOSE EXTRA STAFF
PEOPLE ARE THEY SUPPORTING THE
FOR THE PROGRAMS ON THE GROUND
OR THE PROVIDING. THE SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE LEVEL FOR THE
ARE WE ACTUALLY FUNDING
POSITIONS- AND THEN I WOULD
GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE OUR- OUR KIDS ARE
STABLE. IT GOES BACK TO THE
INITIAL PLACEMENT SO I HOPE OF
PUTTING AS MUCH FOCUS ON THE
PLACEMENT OF CHILDREN. AS WELL
AS- SUSTAINING AND MAINTAINING
A PLACEMENT. DR GRANT. OKAY
THEN I THINK WE WILL RECESS
THIS UNTIL WE ARE FINISHED WITH
SESSION.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX
CONTINUING FROM. ONE TO FIVE.
TO GET HAVE A PRESENTATION FROM
THE DEPARTMENT. OKAY. MR ROSE.
SORRY FOR CAUGHT YOU BY
SURPRISE WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
ISSUE NUMBER SIX. THANK YOU
NUMBER SIX IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT
MY COLLEAGUE JUSTIN FREITAS
WILL COVER THAT STARTED WITH
QUESTION NUMBER ONE AND THEN
I'LL JUMP IN ON. WITH SOME
PROGRAM ASPECTS OF THAT AND
ANSWER THE FINAL QUESTIONS. FOR
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR FREITAS. YES- JUST
APPRAISED BARBADIANS TO ADD
THAT TO THE QUESTION IS A PART
OF A PLAN TO IN PLACE TO
IMPLEMENT OPTIONAL PART ONE
SECTION OF. THE FEDERAL FAMILY
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT OF
OTHER FAMILIES FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICE THANKS GIVE ME- YES TO-
WORST. FINALIZING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SHOULD BE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PROPOSAL- WE'RE
ANTICIPATING ON HAVING
SOMETHING AVAILABLE- WITHIN THE
NEXT DAY OR SO TO SHARE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE- THAT WILL
INCLUDE IMPLEMENTATION OF PART
ONE AS WELL AS- IMPLEMENTATION
APART FOR. THE FUNDING THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROPOSALS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH. THE PART ONE
REQUIREMENTS- BUT THAT WE WILL
HAVE THE LANGUAGE ARE THERE
WILL BE LANGUAGE IN THERE
THAT'S INCLUDED. FOR PART ONE
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL. THANK
YOU AGAIN GREAT ROSE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT NOT SPEAK I THINK.
MISTER FREEZE MENTIONED THAT-
THE FUNDING IS AVAILABLE FOR IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR PART
FOR- IN THAT AND- AND NOT FOR
PART ONE JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE CHECKS I WASN'T SURE
IT WAS ENTIRELY CLEAR- AND THEN
I WITH RESPECT TO THE PLAN THE
PLAN ITSELF SO THE IN ORDER TO.
TO OPERATIONALIZE THE FEDERAL.
I ACT WE- WITH THE DEPARTMENT
DOES NEED TO SUBMIT A
PREVENTION SERVICES PLAN. TO
THAT END WE HAD SOME
STAKEHOLDER- GATHERINGS- PRIOR
TO ECHO THAT ACTUALLY ANNIE AND
GATHERED. INPUT AT THAT POINT.
AND ARE CONTINUING TO DO SO.
UPDATE ON WHERE WE ARE AT THE
MOMENT IS THAT WE HAD A VERY
SUCCESSFUL STAKEHOLDER- SUNDAY
OF LAST WEEK IT WAS A TWO DAY
SUMMIT DAY ONE AT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PARTICIPANTS
THAT- CHIU- THAT LEARN. MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE ACT AND-
ESPECIALLY RELATIVE TO THE
PREVENTION SERVICES ASPECT OF
IT AND- THEN THE STATE SHE WAS
COUNTY TEAMS WE HAD ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FOLKS THAT PARTICIPATED
IN THAT. THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
PLAN IS BEING DRAFTED IS
CONSISTENT WITH. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL- AND- WE
ANTICIPATE A AND ON- JULY
AUGUST WINDOW IN WHICH WE WOULD
SUBMIT A PLAN FOR OCTOBER
APPROVAL. BEFORE THAT TIME WE
INTEND TO HAVE. AT LEAST TWO
DRAFTS AVAILABLE FOR
STAKEHOLDER COMMENT- IN SOME
WEBINARS TO SEEK SUCH COMMENT
AND WE HAVE COMMITTED TO OUR
TRIBAL. COMMUNITY TO HAVE
TRIBAL CONSULTATION AND- WE- SO
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AT A
DISTANCE WITH THE- WITH THE OUR
PROGRAMMATIC ASPECTS OF FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT
PREVENTION SERVICES PLAN. WITH
RESPECT TO- THAT THE NEXT
QUESTION YOU ASKED. WAS- WELL
THIS IS TO ABOUT FAMILY
PRESERVATION AND FAMILY- AND
FAMILIES MAINTENANCE PROGRAMS.
LET ME LET ME JUMP INTO THOSE-
IF I CAN BE BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS THE ONLY MAINTENANCE
AND FAMILY PRESERVATION ARE IN
ESSENCE OPTIONAL PLAN OPTIONAL
PROGRAMS- FOR COUNTIES TO
ADMINISTER SAID I'LL STATE AND
WANTED A TIME IF I MAY BE THE-
FAMILY MAINTENANCE. PROGRAM
CURRENTLY HAS 240-009-0060
THREE CHILDREN BEING SERVED IN
A THESE ARE THESE ARE CHILDREN
BEING SERVED IN IN THE FAMILY
UP THERE IN THE HOME OF THEIR
BIOLOGICAL FAMILY TO CLEAN THE
SERVICES ARE ABOUT SIX MONTHS
IN DURATION ALTHOUGH THEY CAN
GO. UP TO A YEAR- THESE
SERVICES ARE- SOMETIMES COURT
ORDERED AND SOMETIMES VOLUNTARY
AND THEY'RE USED TO IT TO
STABILIZE THE FAMILY AND
ADDRESS CHALLENGES THAT MAY BE.
IMPACTING SAFETY. SOMETIMES
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE TIME
THESE THIS THIS PROGRAM IS USED
AS- KIND OF A- AFTER THE CHILD
HAS BEEN REUNIFIED FROM FOSTER
CARE WITH THAT WITH THEIR
PARENTS. I'M STANDING AND
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED TO THE
FAMILY- TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THE REUNIFICATION PROCESSES ARE
ARE SUPPORT. I SHOULD NOTE ALSO
THAT TITLE FOR B. AND THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ACT AS THE
PRIMARY FUNDING SOURCE FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND IT'S A IT'S A IT'S
A IT'S A FUNDING SOURCE THAT
COUNTIES USUALLY GOES- CLAIM IN
ITS ENTIRETY. BEFORE THE END OF
THE SECOND QUARTER AND MAKES UP
ABOUT 1% OF THE TOTAL CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES ON TO GRADUATE
FROM FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WITH
RESPECT TO FAN PRESERVATION
THEIR WEB PROGRAMS THERE WAS.
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO A LITTLE
ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY OVER TWENTY
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A STATE
FAMILY PRESERVATION PROGRAM
THAT WAS INITIATED BY STATUTE.
THE SHORT WINDOW OF TIME FOR
CAN'T FOR COUNTIES TO KIND OF
INNOCENCE OCT INTO FOURTEEN
COUNTIES DID OPT INTO THAT
PROGRAM. BACK IN IN THOSE DAYS.
THE FUNDING WAS REALIGNED INTO
THE TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT AND- THAT SEVENTEEN
MILLION TWO HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND- IS USED TO
MATCH SOME FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
PREVENTION AND- EARLY
INTERVENTION AND POST ADOPTIVE
SERVICES. THE SERVICES IN THE
IN THE FAMILY PRESERVATION
PROGRAM THAT THE FOURTEEN
COUNTIES ARE OPERATE. INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE COUNSELING-
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT-
PARENTING SOME RESPITE SOME
DAYS STATE TREATMENT
TRANSPORTATION HOW MAKING A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS THAT WOULD
MAKE. MAKE IT- MAKE IT POSSIBLE
FOR- FOR FAMILIES THAT ARE OVER
BURDENED TO BE SUPPORTED TO
KEEP THEIR CHILDREN. IN THE
HOME. THE LAST QUESTION IN THIS
SECTION HOW TO DO WITH- POWELL
PRESIDENT HOW WILL THE FAMILY
FIRST PRESERVATION SERVICES
THAT ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO- MORE
CONTENT HELLO MORE COMPLETE
CONTINUING. CONTINUING THE
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN SHOULD
NOTE THAT. THE THAT THE ACT IS
IN AS I THINK MISTER FREEZE
DESCRIBED EARLIER IS IN TWO
PARTS THE WASHINGTON SEPARATE
PARTS TO OUR REALLY REALLY
GERMANE TO THIS DISCUSSION.
WITH HER AND WITH IT IN THE
BUDGET. ONE IS THE PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT IN PART FOR IS
THAT CONGREGATE CARE PIECE WITH
RESPECT TO THE US THE
PREVENTION SERVICES PIECE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- A LOT OF
THOSE- THIS OPTIONAL PROGRAM TO
BE IMPLEMENTED BY STATES AN
AVERAGE AND JURISDICTIONS. AND
FROM A POP ON A POLICY BASIS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IS
THE FIRST TIME THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD OUT OUTSIDE OF
ANY CHILD WELFARE WAIVER
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT HAS
ALLOWED FOR. FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
ARE TYPICALLY USED FOR CARE AND
SUPERVISION OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN
FOSTER CARE TO BE. USED FOR-
PREVENTION INTERFOR CARES WHEN
WE THE PREVENTION IN THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT
IS PREVENTION INTO FOSTER CARE
IT'S NOT. PREVENTION CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH. STANDPOINT LIKE PRIMARY
PREVENTION OR SECOND YEAR. SO
THAT. IT DOES ALLOW US. ADDED
TO. THE STATE OUR COUNTY WITH
OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES
IMPLEMENTING TO FOR THE FIRST
TIME TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES- FOR- SERVICES
TO PREVENT CHILDREN GOING INTO
FOSTER CARE. CONGRESS HAS
ATTACHED TO MANY STRINGS TO
THESE FUNDS- THAT INCLUDED-
THAT ONLY CERTAIN PROPORTIONS
OF EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES ARE
IDENTIFIED BY FEDERAL CLEARING
HOUSE CAN BE USED. AND IT ALSO
REQUIRES REQUIRES- THAT THE
THAT STATES TO IMPLEMENT THE
STANDARD OF- OF. CANDIDACY FOR
FOSTER CARE WITCHING WHICH WILL
REQUIRES THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
WOULD BE I AM AT RISK SO IT
DOES ALLOW OUR PREVENTIONS ARE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SHOULD JUST TO
STRETCH A LITTLE BIT A LITTLE
BIT MORE TOWARDS PREVENTION BUT
THIS IS CERTAINLY NO- ARTICLED
AT THE END OF A RAINBOW BUT IT
IS. IMPORTANT POLICY CHANGES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. RESPECTIVE
PARK FOR THEIR I THINK OF. IT
ALSO ALLOWS US TO THINK ABOUT A
MORE COMPLETE CONTINUUM OF CARE
IN IS IN THAT ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS AND PARKS FOR IS. IT
ONE OF THE PROVISIONS IN PART
FOR IS A- QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS TO MAKE. MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION FOR A YOUNG
PERSON TO ENTER INTO CONCRETE
CARE IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
THEY NEED TO IT IS IT THEY NEED
TO OFFERA KIND OF THE CLINICAL
OPINION ABOUT WHETHER CONGRESS
HERE MAKES THE MOST SENSE OR IF
THERE ARE OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES THAT SHOULD BE.
EMPLOYED IN ADVANCE OF THAT AND
SO THIS THIS PROCESS WITH A
LITTLE WITH A- EIGHTY EIGHT IT
CLINICAL ASSESSMENT AS PART OF
THE OF THE DETERMINATION TO
GOING INTO OUT OF HOME CARE.
AND WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S LIMITATION ON.
YOUNG PEOPLE OF THE CONDITIONS
IN WHICH YOUNG PEOPLE CAN BE
PLACED IN CONGREGATE CARE ALSO
WILL HELP. PUT SOME EMPHASIS ON
THE ON THE SUPPORTED BUILDING
OF COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
SIMILARLY THE PROVISION OF THE
AFTER CARE PROVISION IN THE IN
THE LAW. ALLOWS FOR ACTUALLY
REQUIRES FOR. THE PROVISION OF
AFTER CARE SERVICES AFTER
EIGHTY EIGHT PLACEMENT EPISODE
AND A SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM OR AS
THEY'RE KNOWN IN SEVERAL. AND
THESE AFTER CARE SERVICES
LARGELY BEING CONCEPTUALIZED
AFTER OUR WRAPAROUND MODEL.
AGAIN HAVE THESE THESE HIGH
QUALITY AND INTENSIVE SERVICES.
MORE AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE
TO BE PROVIDED IN A NUMBER OF
SETTING SO. INTO TOTALITY I
THINK THE FAMILY THIRDS
PREVENTION SERVICE ACT DOES
PROVIDE US WITH A BIT MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD OUT THE
CONTINUE CARE ON AS WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT OVER THE YEARS.
WITH THAT I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES MY- MY REMARKS TO
THIS SECTION OF. ANSWER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYTHING ELSE MISTER FREEZE
FROM THE PART OF FINANCE. CHAU
CON AND HAD JUST OPENED FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. IF NEEDED OKAY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE
PLEASE. THANK YOU- DENTAL SHORT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FEDERAL
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT OF PSA- WITH THE
UPCOMING FEDERAL DEADLINE OF
OCTOBER FIRST- TO IMPLEMENT NEW
CONGREGATE CARE REQUIREMENTS.
WE EXPECT TO SEE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION DETAILING HOW THIS
IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENTATION WILL
OCCUR- AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY
THAT LEGISLATION IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE BUT WE DO ANTICIPATE
THAT IT WILL BE AVAILABLE SOON-
IN ADVANCE OF RECEIVING THAT
LANGUAGE SO AND BEING ABLE TO
REVIEW IT. MANY OF OUR INITIAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT FF PSA
IMPLEMENTATION- REALLY ARE MORE
TECHNICAL FOR EXAMPLE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ROSE MENTIONED- A
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ASSESSING THE
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATENESS OF
CONGREGATE CARE PLACEMENTS NOW
WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT- WHO
WILL BE ELIGIBLE TO FILL THIS
ROLE- WHAT IS THE TIMELINE FOR
IDENTIFYING AND SELECTING THE
IS QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS WHAT
IS THE PLAN FOR TRAINING THEM.
ETCETERA WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT
MANY OF THESE MORE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WILL BE ADDRESSED IN
UPCOMING LANGUAGE AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO ENSURE WE FULLY UNDERSTANDS
THAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ONCE IT'S AVAILABLE. AND THEN
REGARDING- ACTIVITIES AIMED AT
PREVENTING ENTRY INTO FOSTER
CARE WHICH AGAIN- AS WAS NOTED
THESE ACTIVITIES WILL BE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL TITLE FOR
YOU FUNDING ONCE THE STATE HAS
COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH FMVSS
CONGREGATE CARE REQUIREMENTS-
AGAIN WE HAVE A NUMBER. OF
QUESTIONS THERE BUT WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT FORTHCOMING
LANGUAGE- WILL HELP ADDRESS OUR
QUESTIONS- BUT FOR EXAMPLE- ONE
OF OUR INITIAL QUESTIONS AS
WHETHER OR NOT- ANY GENERAL
FUND FUNDING WOULD BE PROVIDED
TO HELP COUNTIES- IT. INITIALLY
IMPLEMENTED ANY OF THESE NEW
ACTIVITIES BUT AGAIN- ONE. THE
LANGUAGE IS A BILL WE WILL BE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH THE-
COMMITTEE STAFF TO COMMUNICATE
FURTHER QUESTIONS AT THAT TIME
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I GUESS I WILL- I WILL
DO I WILL- JUST JOIN WITH THE
L. A. O. AND SAYING WE COULD
ASK A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS AND
TECHNICAL ISSUES BUT I THINK IT
DELUDE BEST IF WE CAN REACT TO
THE PLAN ONCE IT'S PRESENTED.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY IT'S GONNA
BE BY OCTOBER AND WE'RE NOT
COMPLIANCE SO. THAT I
UNDERSTAND IS A PANDEMIC BUT AS
AS EFFICIENTLY AS WE CAN
DEVELOP THAT. AND BEEN WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTNERS
TO MAKE SURE CENTER KIND OF
BEHIND THE CLOCK HERE THAT WE
DON'T LEAVE THINGS OUT. DR
GRANT. I GUESS THAT JUST
BRIEFLY- IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE F. F. PSA
IT IS THIS GONNA IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT IS TO
DO THIS PURELY THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS OR IS THERE A
POLICY COMPONENT THEY'LL BE
COMING FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES. TWO GUYS THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- CENTER
PANTSUIT THIS IS GOING TO BE-
POLICY PROCESS THROUGH THE
BUDGETS- THAT'S WHY WE ARE
ANTICIPATING HAVING THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. THE COMPANY IN
THIS TO YOU VERY SHORTLY- BUT
THERE WILL NOT BE A POLICY AS A
SEPARATE NON FISCAL POLICY
BILL. IT'LL BE DISCUSSED THE
BUDGET IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL. OKAY. I CAN CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND SOME OF WHY THAT'S
THE CASE YES- YES THEY DO HAVE
SOME CONCERN BECAUSE THERE'S
SOME SUBSTANTIAL DIFFERENCES
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
AND I KNOW WE WORKED VERY HARD
ON OUR CONTINUES CARE REFORM
BEFORE AND THERE WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL BODY OF WORK THAT
WAS DONE NOT ONLY BY
ADMINISTRATION ALSO BY THE
LEGISLATURE- I THINK PRIOR TO
THIS ADMINISTRATION. SO AS THE-
YOU KNOW I AS THE PROCESS MOVES
ALONG I THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO. ALSO ENGAGE THE
POLICY CAN BE A CERTAIN LEVEL
IN TERMS OF REVIEWING SOMEOF
THE PROPOSED CHANGES THAT ARE
COMING THROUGH I REALIZE
THERE'S A TIME ISSUE- BUT- I
JUST WANT TO BE. SURE THAT WERE
WERE VETTING THIS POLICY
PROPOSALS THOROUGHLY VETTED THE
ORIGINAL CON CONTINUE OF CARE
REFORM PROPOSALS AND- IS WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS SO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR PAN- AND SO I
GUESS I WOULD ASK IN LIGHT OF
THE- IT'S GOING TO THE BUDGET
WHEN DO YOU THINK WE'LL HAVE
THAT LANGUAGE AND ARE THERE ANY
DRAFTS AVAILABLE FOR US AT THAT
TIME AT THIS TIME THAT WE CAN
START LOOKING AT. JUST REYES.
YES ACTUALLY ADAM WE ANTICIPATE
HAVING. FINALIZED LANGUAGE
THERE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
WARNED TO SPENDING TODAY- BUT I
DO WE DO HAVE- DRAFT LANGUAGE
THAT WE CAN SHARE WITH WITH THE
LEGISLATION EL AL. THE
DOCUMENTS DID IT BE BECAUSE
GOING THROUGH THE BUDGET WITH
NO LEGISLATION IS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE DETAILS OF THE
FULL CONTINUUM OF CARE.
ESPECIALLY AS CHANGES RELATED
TO CHANGES. OKAY SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
APPROVED RELATIVE CARE GIVING
FUNDING ELIGIBILITY. THANK YOU
AGAIN GREG ROSE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT IF I MAY JUST WANTED
TO- MENTIONED THAT PRIOR TO THE
RECESS- FOR THE FLOOR SESSION
YOU AND HAD MADE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS MADE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
REPATRIATION REPATRIATION OF
YOUNG PEOPLE BACK TO.
CALIFORNIA OUT OF- OUT OF THE
STATE GROUP HOMES AND I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE ONE COMMENT IF I
COULD I JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT
WE DO PUBLISH WEEKLY UPDATES
FOR ON THE OUTCOMES OF WHERE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THEY AND
THEY ARE- IN VARIOUS LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S- IN IN-
IN- IT PROGRAMS- SOME. IN
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS I'M IN
FOSTER HOMES- IN IN DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS. WE HAVE IN FACT
ALSO. LEGISLATOR STAFF AND THE
LEAD BY COMMITTEE STAFF. AS
WELL SO JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT YOU'RE
AWARE AND WE'LL MAKE THAT.
DOCUMENT AVAILABLE TO YOU.
THANKS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
CHANGE THAT- THAT THAT LIBERTY
WITH RESPECT TO- ISSUE SEVEN
APPROVED WROTE YOUR CAT
RELIGION CARE GIVER
ELIGIBILITY. ARE FINDING
ELIGIBILITY THIS REDUCED THIS
POLICY IS REALLY INTENDED TO
CREATE PARITY FOR CHILDREN THAT
ARE PLACED IN RELATIVE CARE
GIVERS HOMES OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU MAY RECALL THAT
IN YEARS PAST WE PROVIDE WEEK
WE WORK TOGETHER.
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE AND
ADVOCATES ON ON A POLICY THAT.
PROVIDED FUNDING. FOR A
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS IN ADVANCE
OF COMPLETING THE ENTIRE-
RELATIVE APPROVAL PROCESS WE
TRY TO CHASE A LITTLE BIT ON
THAT EARLIER IN THE HEARING.
THIS LANGUAGE SIMPLY MAKES THAT
SAME THAT SAME POLICY AND THAT
PRACTICE OF AVAILABLE TO YOUNG
PEOPLE TO CARE GIVERS WHEN THE
COURT DETERMINES THAT IT'S IN
THEIR BEST INTEREST TO BE
PLACED WITH A RELATIVE OR A NON
RELATED EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER.
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
HAPPENS PERIODICALLY. AS THE
AGENDA NOTES SO- THAT'S THAT'S
THE POLICY OBJECTIVE OF THIS
TRAILER BILL THAT IS AVAILABLE
FOR REVIEW THANK YOU. PARTY
FINANCING. THE THING. OF VALUE
I DON'T SEE YOUR HAND UP. I
JUST AND WE REVIEWED THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS AT THIS TIME
YEAH THIS IS A WERE THE ISSUE
DR GRANT. OKAY AND I THINK THAT
IS THAT IT THANK INCLUDES THE-
BCPS FOR TODAY AND NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON AND I BELIEVE REALLY-
YOU'RE GONNA STAY HERE WITH US.
I WOULD GO OVER THE PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENT RELATING TO
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES AGAIN
USUALLY THE ADVOCATES OR- THE
PEOPLE PROPOSING WOULD DO THE
READING OF THIS. BUT BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC WE'RE GONNA S.
ELLIE- JUST TO BRIEFLY GIVE
READ THE TITLE AND A AND A
BRIEF SUMMARY. BRIEF YES THANK
YOU- AND I'LL ALSO JUST NOTE IN
MANY CASES WE- ARE STILL
LEARNING ABOUT THE DETAILS OF
THESE PROPOSALS- SO WE LIKELY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
TODAY. BUT CERTAINLY WE CAN
WORK WITH THE- WITH THE
ADVOCATES AND GET BACK TO YOU
WITH ANY- ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT'S NEEDED- SO
WITH THAT I WILL BEGIN THERE
ARE ELEVEN PROPOSALS TOTAL.
NUMBER ONE INCREASE FUNDING FOR
THE EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
FOR FOSTER CHILDREN CHILDREN
NOW THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION
CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
U. S. C. XANDER MARC PACK
SCHOOL SOCIAL WORK REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONGOING FOR THE
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM. THIS WILL ADD TO THE
FORTY ONE MILLION ALREADY
ALLOCATED FOR THE PROGRAM
BRINGING TOTAL FUNDING TO
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION. NUMBER
TWO IMPROVE PERMANENCY OUTCOMES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH REINVEST AND
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS. DO YOU CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER REQUEST FIVE
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
ON GOING TO HELP STABILIZE THE
EFFORT FACED SOCIAL WORKER WORK
FORCE. NUMBER THREE. CHILD
WELFARE CARE GIVER CAREGIVER
STIPENDS THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND CHILDREN
OUT REQUEST SEVENTY THREE POINT
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME TO PROVIDE A ONE HUNDRED
DOLLAR PER MONTH STIPEND FOR
CHILDREN PLACED IN A RESOURCE
FAMILY. WITHIN APPROVED
RELATIVE CAREGIVER AND ALL K.
THROUGH TWELVE FOSTER STUDENTS.
NUMBER FOUR CASH ASSISTANCE FOR
COWARDS FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE. THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
REQUESTS NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND ON GOING TO PROVIDE CARE
HOURS FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN PLACED INTO FOSTER
CARE TO RECEIVE MONTHLY CASH
ASSISTANCE FOR A PERIOD OF UP
TO ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS
WHILE ACTIVE REUNIFICATION
EFFORTS ARE ONGOING. THE
REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR AUTOMATION
COSTS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. NUMBER FIVE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES PREVENTION
SERVICES. BE IT- COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REQUESTS
FIFTY MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONGOING
MATCHED WITH AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES IN BUILDING SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS TO AVOID FOSTER
CARE ENTRIES AND PREVENT CHILD
MALTREATMENT. NUMBER SIX
SUPPORTING VULNERABLE MINORS IN
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES. THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
AND THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH REQUEST ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND TWO POINT TWO MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR SUPPORT MINERS UNABLE TO
ACCESS FOSTER CARE DO YOU TO
COURT CLOSURES OR DELAYS AS A
RESULT OF THE CORVETTE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WEST ALSO INCLUDES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ENACT
THIS CHANGE. SEVEN ENSURING
THAT AS T. R. T. P.'S ACHIEVE
STABILITY THROUGH A ONE TIME
CODE NINETEEN RELIEF.
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES REQUESTS
THIRTY MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND TWELVE MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE TO
PROVIDE A ONE TIME BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO STABILIZE AS TIER
TEEPEES. NUMBER EIGHT FUNDING
FOR THE PARENTS ANONYMOUS
STATEWIDE HELPLINE AND PARENT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH GROUPS.
PARENTS ANONYMOUS REQUEST THREE
MILLION PER YEAR OVER THE NEXT
THREE FISCAL YEARS TO SUPPORT
THE PARENTS ANONYMOUS HELPLINE.
NUMBER NINE PREVENTING AND
REDUCING FOSTER CARE FOSTER
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS. JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH REQUESTS
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWO MILLION ANNUALLY
THERE AFTER TO HELP PROVIDE
HOUSING STABILITY FOR CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTHS.
NUMBER TEN HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH EXTENDING THE
INVENT SUPPLEMENTS. JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS THE
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW REQUEST
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND I'M GOING TO EXTEND
THE INVINCIBLE MEANT PAYMENTS.
AND NUMBER ELEVEN FULLY FUNDS
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
WORKLOAD IN THE C. C. R. TRUE
UP. THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REQUESTS
EIGHTY MILLION GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY TO FULLY FUND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL WORKLOADS. THAT
CONCLUDES THE PROPOSALS FROM
ADVOCATES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE AND I THINK THAT WILL
CONCLUDE THE BUSINESS ITEMS WE
ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS- AND I DIDN'T JUST A
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING THE
PROPOSALS. WAIT OKAY NOW WE'RE
TO GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS I
WOULD SAY AGAIN THE NUMBER FOR
CALLING IN IS. 844-291-6358 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FIVE ZERO
FOUR ZERO SEVEN FOUR- THAT IS
ACCESS COBRA I FIRST ASK IF
THERE'S ANY BODY WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW MOVED
TO THE- MODERATOR TO OPEN THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE
SECURE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YOU MAY
WITHDRAW YOURSELF FROM THE
QUEUE AT ANY TIME BY REPEATING
THE ONE AND ZERO COMMAND. IF
YOU'RE USING A SPEAKER PHONE.
PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS.
ONCE AGAIN PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX CENTS ONE TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GREAT THANK
YOU CAN LIMITS ARE PLANNING TO
CLIENTS TODAY CHILDREN NOW
WHICH IS FROM SUPPORT OF THE
BFF INVESTMENT ONE TWO ZERO
THREE FIVE AND NINE. AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
IN SUPPORT OF PDFS INVESTMENTS
ONE TWO SIX NINE. MEMBER YOU
TUCKER BRIDGE IF YOU HEARD THIS
MORNING THE CHILD CARE AT THE
DEMONSTRATION AND THIS PROGRAM
IS CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING THE
FACT THAT THE FIFTY YARD MAKING
THE FIRST. PLACEMENT FOR THEIR
TWELVE YEAR OLD COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM. THERE'S A GREAT NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL NAVIGATORS HELP
RESOURCE FAMILIES AND NON
MANNER DEPENDENTS HAVE LONG
TERM. CARE PLANS AND THE
PROVISION ADDITIONAL TRAUMA
INFORMED TRAINING WILL NOT ONLY
BENEFIT CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
BUT ALL CHILDREN. INCLUDING
THAT HAVE RECEIVED THE
TRAINING. ON THE SUPPORTING
VULNERABLE MINORS PROPOSAL WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE DELAYED THE
BACKLOG IN THE COURT SYSTEM
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE COME INTO CHILD
WELFARE MAY NOT BE TURNING
EIGHTEEN. WE ARE GRATEFUL ISSUE
PREVIOUSLY WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND WERE ABLE TO DRIVE PART OF
THE PROBLEM. AB SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT AM TWENTY NINETEEN YET
ARE STILL WAITING ON PDFS
ISSUED THE AT THE ALCHEMIST AND
BELL. OKAY JUST CAME OUT
VERTICAL TO COMMENT WITH MY
KNOWING THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION COOPER TO
PREVENTING YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
AGING OUT OF UFC WE HOPE THAT
YOU CAN SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE
WOULD OTHERWISE MEET THE
TECHNICIAN. YOU CAN EXPECT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WOULD ASK PEOPLE TO TRY
TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WILL I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FOR NINE ONE FOUR NINE YOUR
LINE OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM AND
MEMBERS OF THE- WITH THE COUNTY
DURING OF. AS YOU HEARD WIENER
CLOSED CHILDREN OUR THINKING
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO ALLOW COUNTIES TO BUILD
A COMMUNITY DRIVEN. STOMACH
PREVENTION SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES TO REDUCE CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT AND FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENTS WE WANT TO USE
A LIMITED PREVENTION SERVICES
AUTHORIZED UNDER PART ONE OF
THE FAMILIES FIRST ACT AS A
JUMPING OFF POINT. FOR A BROAD
INCLUSIVE PREVENTION MODEL THAT
ADDRESSES KNOWN DISPARITIES IN
FOSTER CARE INVOLVEMENT AND
OUTCOMES AMONG FAMILIES THAT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WE ALSO
ARE AGAIN SEEKING FUNDING THE
TRUCK COUNTIES RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL FUNDING UNDER THE
CONTINUOUS CARE OF FORM WHICH
WE BELIEVE IS SUBJECT TO
PROPOSITION THIRTY
REQUIREMENTS. THIS IS EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR A CHANGE TO THE CAL
WORKS ROLE THAT WOULD ALLOW
FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN ARE
PLACED IN THE FOSTER CARE TO
CONTINUE RECEIVING THE PARENTS
PORTION OF THE GRANT. PROVIDED
THEY ARE AN EFFORT TO REUNIFY
SUPPORTING FAMILIES TO MAINTAIN
OUR HOUSING IS THE FUNDS CAN.
THAT THE WHOLE TO INSURING
CHILDREN THANK. YOU RETURN HOME
THANK YOU VERY. THE
ADMINISTRATION IDENTITY AS OUR
PROPOS ITEM ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
I WILL PROVIDE A AND WRITING ON
OF THE ITEMS THINK VERY MUCH
I'D RELATED THE OUT OF STATE
GROUPS. I'M NOT COMMENT THAT
BELIEVE UNDERWRITER. I DON'T
JUST MEAN FOR. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHAT LITTLE I
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
THAT'S ONE ONE THREE ONE IS A-
I. WITH THAT- LARYNGOLOGY
EVERYTHING IS A PART OF THAT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE AS
A REMINDER IF YOU ARE VIEWING
ON THE WEB YOU NEED TO MUTE
YOUR LINE ON THAT SIDE OR ELSE
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU
LINE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU NEED TO MEET. MEET
YOUR LINE PLEASE MEET WHATEVER
YOU'RE WATCHING ON. WE. YEAH
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON MOVE
ON PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WELL NUMBER ONE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR THAT'S
ONE FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME MY NAME IS BARB. AND
I WORK FOR A STATEWIDE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY AND SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC. M.
PROVIDER. WE SERVED THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA IT CHILDREN EACH
YEAR. WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE FOLLOWING PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT RELATED IT CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES. ITEMS YOU
TENDING TO HELP STABILIZE AT
THAT DATE SO CHAU WORKER WORKS
FORCED. TO SHOP THE BILL IT IT
IS ONE AID- SUPPORT- BOB YOUR
IN. FAVOR KERN ENTERPRISE IT AT
A ALL ADEQUATE EIGHT FOUR ARE
TO WORK RESULT HI- NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ON OUR FOSTER YOUTH
PERMITTED EACH DURING THE
ESPECIALLY ANGELA IN HOW. LINE
OF WORK- TO. ARKPORT FOR
OFFICER USED AND SEVEN AND AS
IN NANCY T. PROVIDER WE HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
IT I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR
ONE TRYING TO FIND. A VISOR
PROGRAMS DO TO COPE AT NINETEEN
DRIVEN THAT IS IMPACT. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR SUPPORT
EACH. OTHER CREDIT. CALL BUDGET
REQUEST. I DON'T WANT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEXICO PLEASE I.
THANK YOU WILL GO AYE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE ONE FOR
NINE YOUR LINE IS A- HELLO MY
NAME IS MAGGIE AND I'M- A
PARENT WITH PARENTS ANONYMOUS.
I'M GLAD TO BE ABLE THINK
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND I'M PART
OF IT TO CONTINUE FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PLANNING. HELP
FIND SUPPORT GROUPS. THAT ARE
BEING OPERATED BY PARENTS
MONUMENT. BROWN THE LAST TWO
DAYS. BEFORE THE MOTION TO FIND
HELP. THANK YOU THINK. AND
CHILDREN UNLESS YOU PROVIDE THE
AND NOBODY ON THE TEAM IN. THE
NEXT THIRTY TO FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. BRENT AN AUTOMATIC
AND THE- UNDERSTANDING YOUR I
HAVE. MIGHT EVEN. WITHOUT THE
COULD. CHARACTER TO BE ABLE TO
COME TO GIVE UP THE MOTION
ACCORDING. THAT WE PARENTS AND
CHILDREN I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WORLD. WE RECEIVED A CALL FROM.
THE REASON WHY I'M HERE TODAY
TRACK YOU. NEED TO MAKE A
FUNDING AND ACT NOW. HOW MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER.
PLEASE THANK YOU WILL GO LINE
NUMBER HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
THAT'S ONE FOUR ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ON GOING
OUT. I AM HONORED TO SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY- THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTINUING THE FUNDING NOW FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PARENT AND YOUR
HELPLINE AND GROUPS OPERATED BY
PARENTS ANONYMOUS WAY TO CLOSE
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH.
UNLESS YOU PROVIDE THE ANNUAL
FUNDING OF THIRTEEN MILLION
NEEDED FOR EACH OF THE NEXT
THREE YEARS I AM A PROUD NATIVE
MET A MEXICAN AMERICAN MOTHER
SEVEN GRANDMOTHER THREE IN THE
CAN PROVIDER AND BECAUSE THE
PARENTS ANONYMOUS I HAVE BEEN
CLEAN FOURTEEN YEARS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC I AND ALL OF MY
CHILDREN SOME WHO ARE PARENTS
THEMSELVES DEPEND ON THE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT WE RECEIVED
EVERY TIME WE CALL THE
CALIFORNIA BURNING IT OUTLINES.
MY FAMILY AND I. TRANSFORMED
HOPE TO THROUGH THE LIGHT LIFE
AFFIRMING EMOTIONAL SUPPORT.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PARENT AND
YOUTH HELPLINES AND PARENTS
ANONYMOUS I AND OTHER
CALIFORNIANS PARENTS CHILDREN
AND YOU HAVE A VITAL SUPPORT
SYSTEM. THROUGH PARENTS
ANONYMOUS THAT IS WHY I AM
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE CONTINUE
THE FINDING AND ACT NOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE. NUMBER
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THAT'S ONE THREE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU SENATOR TELELOGIC MET.
MELENDEZ AND HANDS MY NAME'S
DAN ITS ROOTS AND I LIVE IN
RIVERSIDE. AS A PARENT
GRANDPARENT AND CONSULTED WITH
IRVING NONPROFITS AND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE I AM ENCOURAGING EVEN
IMPLORING YOU TO FIND THE
CALIFORNIA. HEALTHLINE GROUPS
OPERATED BY PARENTS ANONYMOUS
INCORPORATED AT THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
THREE YEARS THAT HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED IN PROPOSAL FORM
BACK COMPLETED. IT'S ALL UP FOR
SERVICES. CUPBOARD NINETEEN
HAVE HAD A TO MY FROM NOW IN.
ON ALL ABOUT. NEGATIVE IMPACTS
INCREASES WITH CHILDREN AT HOME
AND HAVE BEEN EXPONENTIAL
DETRIMENT FOR PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND YOU ALREADY LIVING
IN POVERTY. FURTHER WITH THE
SEVERE LACK OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE STATE
THE CALIFORNIA PARENT AND YOU
HELP WHINING GROUPS IS THE
SIMPLEST WAY FOR PARENTS USED
TO GET IMMEDIATE EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT FROM TRAINED
COUNSELORS. I ASK YOU AGAIN
PLEASE FIND THE CALIFORNIA
PARENTING YOU HELP WHINING
GROUP OPERATED BY PARENTS
ANONYMOUS INCORPORATED AT THE
THREE MILLION DOLLAR LEVELS FOR
THE NEXT THREE YEARS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO
THE LINE NUMBER ONE FIVE FIVE
ONE FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY BY NAME
IS JERRY JOHNSON I AM WITH-
TWENTY OF THEM IS SERVICES I'M
A PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF ALSO BEEN
IN THE FIELD FOR OVER THIRTY
THREE YEARS. AND I AM CALLING
REGARDING NUMBER TWO.
REINVESTING FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS. THE
SALARY JUST TURN THE CAP OUT
BECAUSE OF THE LIMITATIONS WE
HAVEN'T AND STILL BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE BUDGET. ARM SO THE
PROBLEM IS THESE PEOPLE
COMPLAIN JOBS PAYING BETTER
ELSEWHERE AND THESE KIDS NEED
STABILITY IN THE PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORT THEM AND SERVE THEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. EXTRALEGAL
ON NUMBER. ONE SIX SIX. ONE SIX
SIXTY LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON. YES PLEASE PROCEED
FOR ABOUT A MINUTE. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS WENDY **** AND I'M
CALLING WITH THE WAY SAID MARK
BASED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
OUR ORGANIZATION IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE COALITION. AT
YOUR REQUEST. EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION PREVENTING AND
REDUCING FOSTER YOU'D ALMOST.
ALL BERMAN AGENCY WE HAVE
WITNESSED- THAT CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH UNLIKE
THEIR PEERS HAVE BLACK COURT ON
THEIR CARE GIVERS AND EXTENDED
FAMILY. AND THAT MATCH IN
FILLING RECESSION LIMITED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS AND
LIMITED INCOME ALL CHALLENGES
FACING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
WE KNOW THAT BBC DATA SHOWS
JUST HOW DEEP THE PANDEMIC HAS
IMPACTED THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF ALL YOUNG ADULT.
THE DATA 25% OF THOSE SURVEYED
YOUNG ADULTS REPORTED CLEAR
CREEK COUNTY PLANNING SUICIDE
IN THE MONTH PRIOR TO THE
SURVEY. WE BELIEVE THAT NOW
MORE THAN EVER DEDICATED
RESOURCES TO HELP CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH DELEGATE
MULTIPLE SYSTEM ENGINE SURE
THERE HOUSING STABILITY AND THE
COURTS CREDIT ALL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE SIX NINE AND
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE SIX NINE.
MATTHEW PROJECT HELPLINE
DIRECTOR AT PARENTS ANONYMOUS I
AM ASKING FOR THE IMMEDIATE
CONTINUANCE OF FUNDING AND
ONGOING FUNDING FOR TERENCE
MONITOR OPERATE THE CALIFORNIA
PARENTS NEWS HELPLINE AND
ONLINE PARENTS NON EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT GROUPS. AND YOU ALL THE
CHEERING IN THE MIDST OF THE
ONGOING HOPE IT NINETEEN AND
UNDER CALIFORNIA PARENTS
CAREGIVERS CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ARE CURRENTLY CALLING. TEXTING
AND CHATTING TO CALIFORNIA I
NEED HELP LAUNCHERS EVENING
MEDIA EVIDENCE BASED EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THEY NEED. AND
CERTAINLY THOSE ARE. EVERY
PARENT AND CHILD AND CAL SHOULD
EAT ACCESS TO BASED EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THEREFORE I MEAN
COURAGE IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
PARENTS ANONYMOUS GROUPS AND
PARENTS ANONYMOUS CALIFORNIA
PARENTS NEWS OUTLETS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR DEDICATION
TO CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE SEVEN TO
REALIGN IS OPEN ONE SEVEN TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ANNA
JOHNSTON WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE I'M ALSO
CALLING ON BEHALF OF BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS- AND RBC
FUND WHO IS NOT ABLE TO MAKE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT DAY IN
SUPPORT OF HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH ITEM TEN WHICH
WOULD EXTEND THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT. RECEIVER OF A
PRENATAL INCOME SUPPLEMENT CAN
REDUCE THE NEGATIVE MATERNAL
AND CHILD HEALTH OUTCOMES OF
LOW BIRTH WEIGHT AND PRETERM
BIRTH WHILE ALSO INCREASING
POSITIVE OUTCOMES INCLUDING
BREAST FEEDING INITIATION. I
WERE HOPING TO SUPPORT OUR
FOSTER YOUTH WITH HEALTHIER-
BIRTH OUTCOMES AND PARENTING
SUPPORT BY EXTENDING THIS
SUPPLEMENT SO WE APPRECIATE
ANYTHING THE SENATE. BUDGET
COMMITTEE CAN DO TO- INVEST IN
OUR FOSTER YOUTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS CALLER PLEASE
MODERATOR. I STROLLER IS ONE
SEVEN FIVE ONE SEVEN FIVE
DILLON IS OPEN. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON WITH DOWN INSTANTLY
WITH CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER REPRESENT ALL THE
CHILDREN OF LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTY
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLAR
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROPOSAL. TO EXPAND THE
INFANT SUPPLEMENTS AND LET'S
ANGELES COUNTY EXPECTING YOU'D
CURRENTLY RECEIVE THE
INVINCIBLE MEANT THREE MONTHS
PRIOR TO CHILD BIRTH. IN OUR
EXPERIENCE THE SMALL INVESTMENT
HAS MADE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON
THE ABILITY OF OUR CLIENTS TO
PREPARE FOR THE UPCOMING BIRTH
OF THEIR CHILDREN. THE SUPPORT
HAVE GIVEN THEM THE ABILITY TO
PURCHASE NECESSITIES SUCH AS
CAR SEATS DIAPERS WIPES YOU
BROWN CLOSE CRED AND OTHER
ITEMS THAT ARE REQUIRED OF A
PARENT. THE MOMENT THEY LEAVE
THE HOSPITAL. WHEN IT THEY'RE
LEFT SCRAMBLING RESEARCH THE
OTHER VERY. IN STRESSFUL HI IN
THEIR LIFE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINAL
SEVEN SIXTY LINE IS OPEN ONE
SEVEN SIX. HI THIS IS BILL
RICHARD AND I WORK WITH C<c.cyan>G</c>
ANNE OF FAMILY SERVICES I
OVERSEE ONE RSA FOSTER CARE
OFFICE AND ONE S. T. R. T. P. I
WANT TO SUPPORT NUMBER TWO TO
GET A HIGHER PAY FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS WE HAVE. BEEN HIRING
SOCIAL BECAUSE FOR MANY YEARS
HERE AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
FIND THEM FOR WHAT WE PAY. I
ALSO SUPPORTS- RELIEF FROM LAST
YEAR TEEPEES WE HAVE HAD TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF TO COVER
FOR ADDITIONAL- DISTANCE
LEARNING AT THE HOUSE AND WE
ARE. RELEASING SPENDING A LOT
OF MONEY ON PPC AND EVERYTHING
ELSE SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ON THE NEXT
LINE IS FROM ONE SEVEN NINE
HILL AND IS OPEN ONE SEVEN NINE-
MY NAME IS THANK YOU THE BEST
THREE OF THEM WITHIN HALF OF IT
FOR YOU BOB. AND I'M CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA I
AM HERE ON BEHALF OFCOALITION
OF A HUNDRED AND ORGANIZATIONS
ARE WORK. AND WORK OUT. NINE
THOUSAND. IF YOU'RE A FULL IT
THE IN OF WOMEN. IT HAPPEN BOB
WHAT. OKAY HOW CRITICAL NEED
FOR OUR BOB THANK YOU BUT IF
WILL BE A SMALL INVESTMENT BUT
AT. DURING OUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE ONE NINE ZERO ALIGN IS
OPEN ONE NINE ZERO. AFTERNOON
THIS IS SERRA RUBY ON BEHALF OF
THE OFFICE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BLANCA RUBIO- FOR CALLING TO
SUPPORT ITEMS TWO AND TEN- TO
BEING P. INCLUDING CURRENT THE
OUTCOMES FOR FOSTER YOUTH ARE
INVESTING IN FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS AND ITEM
CAN IT BE HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH CHAIR SKINNER AND
WE'LL MAKE OURSELVES AVAILABLE.
TO YOURSELF AS WELL CHAIR AT.
YOUR RATIONS ON YOUR DEDICATED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR.
NINE ONE SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE SEVEN FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS STEVEN
MORALIS. THANK YOU PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT A COUNTY SPRINTED
UP THE- I AM SPEAKING ON ISSUE
NUMBER NINE PRETENDING
EVERYTHING IS BEING FOUGHT TO
KEEP HOMELESSNESS. AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH BERMAN WHO WAS
UNABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FIRST HOUSING I KNOW THE
STRUGGLES THAT ARE YOU GONNA
TALKED BASEBALL TRYING TO
NAVIGATE HOUSING. BUT TRYING TO
MAINTAIN THE JOB AND PURSUE
THEIR EDUCATION IN ADDITION
THEY NOW FACE A PANDEMIC THAT
LIKE ALL OF US HAS BEEN
DEVASTATED. I ENTERED FIRST
CARE AGE SEVEN AND AMOUNTED.
AND PAID EIGHTEEN ALLOW ME TO
PARTAKE IN MANY SERVICES. LIKE
A FULL RIDE SCHOLARSHIP TO THE
FUNDS NATIONAL FOSTER PARENTS
DOES HE TO. ALTHOUGH MANY
OPPORTUNITIES WERE MADE
AVAILABLE HOUSING WAS NOT AND I
STRUGGLED OFTEN HAVING TO FIND
A PLACE TO LAY MY HEAD. I HAVE
STATE ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN AND OUT
OF CARE I ASKED THE SUPPORT
ISSUE NINE AND PLEASE ALLOW
OTHERS TO HAVE THE SAME IMPACT
I'M ABLE TO HAVE TODAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIX COLOR PLEASE. MY
NINETY EIGHT YEAR LINE IS OPEN
NINE AM. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
THE MON CORRECTLY AND I'M WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL.
PREVENTING AND REDUCING BOX FOR
YOU LET'S NOT BECAUSE ITEM
NUMBER NINE. GLOBAL WITH THE
FAB TRAINING FOR TRAVEL WORKERS
AND PROBATION OFFICER. ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM. ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR HOUSING SERVICES
LIKE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING WHICH
CURRENTLY HAVE A WAITING LIST
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED YOU
STATEWIDE. I WANT TO ALSO JUST
NOTE THAT THIS INVESTMENT WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL RESOURCES FOR
ADDRESSING THE CLIP RAISED BY
MEMBERS EARLIER IN THE HEARING
ONE BOX YOU CALL RECEIVING THE
EXTENDED PANDEMIC RELIEF
SERVICES ARE PRECEDING THEM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR COMMITMENT TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE SIX
EIGHT KILL LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIX EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS VERONICA MORALIS I'M
BERMAN AARON AND STANISLAUS
COUNTY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO BILLION IN
INTRODUCED OFF THE HOMELESSNESS
OKAY. I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH WE DID. BE AND NOW I AM
THE I OP COORDINATOR. PERCENT
OF. AS YOU CAN SEE I. HAVE
IMPACT ON HOW. THE DIFFERENT.
IT CONTINUED IN OUR U. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR. ONE NINE
ONE SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AFTERNOON CHRISTIAN POWER
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS. THANK YOU
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED. BUDGET AT
WITH THE PRE APPROVAL FUNDING
EXPANDING THE URGENCY CARE
COVER FUNDING BE AT SIXTY FIVE
DAYS. CHECK MY SUPPORT FOR- ONE
SIX AND THEN. B. THREE FREON
ITEMS THREE REPRESENTED
HOLISTIC AND ACCORDING AGE
CHILD THANKS BOB FOR ALL YOUR
IN THERE IS NO ONE DOLLARS FOR
GRADES K. THROUGH TWELVE. WE
BELIEVE THAT SHOWED IN FOSTER
CARE WHO TO PASS THE STATE THAT
OUR PARENTS MUST BE AMONG THOSE
INDIVIDUALS PRIORITIZED. BUDGET
CHILDREN IN CALGARY PARTICULAR
AS WELL AS- MORE THAN 40% WE'RE
OUT FOR THAT IT WAS FARM. FOR
CHILDREN AT WORK THROUGH COMMA
ALL ALL OF THE ISSUES WITH IT
WITH PATH AND MARK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
LEGAL AND IS OPEN. ONE EIGHT
TWO. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CLINT
BOND AND CROWN CASTLE EXPAND
THIS COUNTY COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATES THE FACT IS
DOWNEY NINE ZERO COALITION
PRACTICAL ISSUE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS EXPRESSED
SUPPORT THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS PREVENTING AND
REDUCING PASTI. WITH ALMOST
MATH. THE PROPOSAL- FROM THE
TURN TWENTY ADDED TO FINDING
WORK AND FINDING A PLACE LIVE
AFTER THE- FOSTER CARE SINCE.
YEAH MY MIND PENTAGON AND
PERSONAL GO ALONG WAY THEM WHEN
IN THE THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
SEVEN THREE LINE IS OPEN ONE
SEVEN THREE. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE MY NAME IS LOUISE
MADRID. TO CLOSE THE REGULAR
WITH DESPAIR AND THEN- WE
OPERATED HOUSING PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE WAY TOO DURING
CALIFORNIA- STARTUP SOME
CONNECTIONS TO CITRIC-
RIVERSIDE JOAQUIN STANISLAUS
SACRAMENTO- TOMORROW WHICH I
KNOW YOU ARE REPRESENT
PARTICULAR YOU'LL MY DOWNTOWN
CHURCH. HELLO MONDAY AND JUST
ONE- YOU KNOW ENCOURAGING HERE
TO SUPPORT- PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT NUMBER NINE THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENT. CAN'T WHAT DO YOU CALL
NEXT PROPOSED TALK THE DATA
THAT YOU HAVE TO YOU ARE
DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS PROBLEM
MAKES AN FROM BOTHA FIFTY AND
HUMAN. POINT OF VIEW I SAY
URGING PLEASE THE SITE ASSIST
THIS PER. DURING INCREASE OF
HOW AND BOTTOM AND THE TOP TWO
IRATE THANK YOU YOUR TIME THANK
VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR PLAY.
NINE ONE TWO THREE LINE IS OPEN
ONE TO THIRTY- HELLO THIS IS
JORDAN CLOSER WITH CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION WE WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OF SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
FOUR HELP FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
IMPRINTS ON PULLMAN. EIGHTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION- FOR THE
PREVENTING AND REDUCING FOSTER
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL AND
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION TO
SUPPORT VULNERABLE MINORS
UNABLE TO ACCESS FOSTER CARE
DUE TO COURT CLOSURES OR
DELAYED AT THE RESULT OF THE
OPEN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WITHOUT
THE NECESSARY SUPPORT AND
PLACED THE ADDED PRESSURES OF
HAVING ABILITY EVERYTHING A
CHILD AS A PROXY YOU CAN
POTENTIALLY POSTOL A USED
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD AS WELL
AS RESULTS AND THEIR CHILDREN
ENDING UP IN FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
THEMSELVES. GIVEN THE IMPACT OF
CO IN NINETEEN AND A HIGHER
PROPORTION OF ALL SHE IS
BECOMING PARENTS IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT YOU RECEIVE THAT TARGETED
THE FOURTEENTH NEED IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THEIR PERSONAL
EDUCATIONAL OR PROFESSIONAL
GOALS BOX WILL BE BEING ABLE TO
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN THEMSELVES.
DURING THESE TIMES. OR MINORS
TO MAKE UNABLE ACCESS SERVICE
UPON CARE WE- THE LEAD. IN CHAO
WILL AND- TO IMPLEMENT THE
OLDER YOU PROVISION OF THE CON-
CONSOLIDATION APPROPRIATIONS
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DIVISION TEN OF THE ACT WHICH
BECAME EFFECTIVE. DECEMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX
COLOR PLEASE. NINE ONE NINE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE INTO.
HELLO COMMITTEE MY NAME IS THE
MAY ORIGINAL JUDGES L. A.
COUNTY AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH LEADING BATTERY AT THE
STATE UNIVERSITY. I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF COURSE NO ONE THREE
EIGHT ORGANIZATIONS. TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT BUT IS THERE ARE TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND ALL THE FEATURES
ABOUT THE YOUTH PROPOSAL. THEN
THE ENTITLEMENT. OKAY
EXPERIENCE DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGH RATES OF PREGNANCY BATES
GREATER HOTELS AND PREPARING
FOR BIRTH. NONPLUSSED PEER AND
KERR GREATER BECAUSE DUE TO
CORPORATE CLIENTS- NAVIGATING
THE CHALLENGES ARE
DISCRETIONARY YOU COLOR.
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTY PROVIDES
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT A
PARENTING CLASS YOU. TO THE
CORRECT CARE ACT WITH VERSION
OF THEIR CHILD. I BELIEVE THAT
DID ARE MISSION BE. ON BE-
GIVING HER PARENTS HONOR EVEN
THREE MONTHS- DEFINITELY DIçN
CHO THEN THE PANDEMIC PARENTS-
BUT YOU CAN'T BE MORE HELP AND
SUPPORT AND I'LL REALLY GREATLY
APPRECIATED THAT BECAUSE THAT
BILL AS WELL. THANK YOU YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX COLOR
PLEASE. NINE ONE FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE FOUR ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DR LISA PYRE
BERLIN THE PRESENT CO PARENTS
ON THE SINK WE OPERATE THE ONLY
CALIFORNIA PAIRING YOU'D
HELPLINE AND OUR ONLINE
EVIDENCE BASED PARENTS ARMS
GROUPS UNDER CO THE CONTRACT
THAT WE STARTED IN PARTNERSHIP
THE CDSS THE GOVERNOR ON FOR
FIFTEEN. BUT WE NEED THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACT NOW TO
AUTHORIZED ADEQUATE FUNDING
OTHERWISE THIS HELPLINE WHICH
IS THE ONLY FIRST RESPONDERS
SYSTEM FOR FAMILIES IN THE
STATE WILL CLOSE. IN A MERE
TWELVE DAYS. WE ARE ASKING FOR
JUST YOU TO SPEND THIRTY TWO
CENTS TO THIRTY TWO CENTS FOR
EACH OF THE NINE POINT THREE
MILLION CHILDREN YOUTH WE HAVE
IN THE STATE. EVERY YEAR THAT'S
ONLY THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EACH OF THE NEXT THREE YEARS SO
WE HAVE CONSISTENCY THAT IS NOT
A START AND STP SO PEOPLE HAVE
A PLACE TO PICK UP THE PHONE.
AND IMMEDIATELY CHAT CALL OR%
TEXT ASK FOR HELP THAT WE
BELIEVE IS A SIGN OF STRENGTH.
THIS EMOTIONAL SUPPORT IS VITAL
DURING THIS TROUBLING TIMES
DISTANCE LEARNING THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC AT CENTER AT CENTER WE
HAVE REACHED PARENTS AND CARE
GIVERS IN USE IN EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY. DERBY MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DIVERSE. PARENTS
CHILDREN YOU. WE ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE THIS FUNDING NOW AND
DEFINE THE FUNDING NOW TO DO IT
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE PARENTS AND KIDS
HAVING NO WHERE TO TURN. TO
PICK UP THE PHONE AND ASK FOR
HELP AND GET THE EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO THEY CAN
THRIVE AND BE RESILIENT MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY AND GET
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC TOGETHER.
WE ARE HERE IN PARTNERSHIP
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR
PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHT IN
FELINE IS OPEN. ONE EIGHT
EIGHT. HI MY BY AND IT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FELICIA
I'M FROM CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH I AM HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COLLISION OF
THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THOSE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND OF THESE
FUTURISTIC FOSTER YOUTH
PROPOSAL. GET EXTEND THE
INTENSE OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS PLEASE. NINE ONE NINE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE NINE
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JANE SCHROEDER I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF FIRST PLACE FOR YOU
ONE OF THE LARGEST PROVIDERS
BUT EXCLUSIVELY THIRTIES AGING
OUT OF FOSTER CARE. WE SEE
FIRSTHAND THE DESPERATE NEED
FOR MORE HOUSING RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T BASED
HOMELESSNESS. AND THE PRESSURES
ON THESE YOUNG ADULTS HAVE
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY UNDER
THE PANDEMIC SO WE'RE HERE
ALONG WITH A COALITION OF OVER
A HUNDRED ORGANIZATION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THAT EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLAR PREVENTING
AND REDUCING COSTS TREAT
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER NINE. I MEAN ALSO
LIKE EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
INFANT DOCUMENT WHICH WILL
REALLY HELP ENSURE THAT-
PREGNANT YOUNG ADULTS AN
EXPANDED FOSTER CARE HOW THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO ACCESS.
MATERNAL HEALTHCARE AND PREPARE
FOR THEIR NEWBORN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KIRTI ANILINE FROM SACRAMENTO I
AM A FORMER FOX NEWS WORKING
WITH LUMBER NOW BECAUSE FOR
YOU. I AM CURRENTLY SIX MONTHS
PREGNANT I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH WHICH INCLUDES THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT BEGINNING IN THE
SEVENTH MONTH OF PREGNANCY ARE
EXPECTING COST. MY FIRST TRY
AND THE PARKLAND AN EXPENSIVE
ARE EXPENSIVE AND BECOMING MORE
SHOCKED BOTH. THE PROJECT INTO
PRIVATE IF. MORE IS NECESSARY
IMPROVISED NEEDING HELP
INSPECTING OTHER BECAUSE WALL
STREET DON'T BENEFIT FROM POWER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. HELLO NINE
ONE NINE NINE YOU'LL AND IS
OPEN ONE NINE NINE. HELLO MY
NAME IS KAYLA BAILEY I AM FROM
PLACES AND I AM A YOU ADVOCATE.
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. FOR THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PRESERVATION AND AREN'T SECTION
OF AUSTRIAN HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL. I AM ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF ONE
TWO EIGHT. I'M SORRY HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN.
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND. THE FUTURES OF FOSTER
YOUTH PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
AND SENSIBLE MEANT- AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND THE CURRENT
ADVOCATE- THIS WILL GREATLY
SUPPORT YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO TAKE
CARE OF A CHILD. MY ONLY
CONCERN IS THAT YOU WHO ARE
PREGNANT AND PARENTING IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM ARE AT A
DISADVANTAGE FOR RESOURCES
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES THIS
WILL PROVIDE A GOOD FIRST STEP
INTO A REPORT BUT COULD
DEFINITELY BE EXPANDED ON IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
IMPORTANT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
SEVEN ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAVID DONE WHEN AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LIKE YOU
KNOW FAMILY THINK OF ARMENIA
ABOUT THE NATURE. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US THE OPPORTUNITY AND FOR
ADVOCATING FOR CHILDREN IN YOUR-
I AM CALLING NOT BEFORE I'M
SUPPOSED TO NUMBER TWO. OUR
PROVIDE COMMUNITIES WILL FOSTER
CHILDREN FOUGHT FOR YOU
ACTUALLY THE- THAT REQUIRED
THAT ARE WITH THE FAUCET CARE.
I DURING THE EXPANDED WE SAW
THE DRUM. COMMAND TO WORK
BETTER WORKERS HAVE GONE ABOVE
AND BEYOND. BY THE MANY
BARRIERS TO CALL THE NINETEEN.
AND HER BECAUSE WE ARE
COMPENSATORS WORKER ACCORDING.
THROUGH THEIR WORK IN THEIR
COMMITMENT. I'VE ALSO ONE AFTER
BOARD PROPOSALS. ONE THREE FIVE
EIGHT SEVEN NINE TEN. ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU SENATORS AND
STAFF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX
COURT PLEASE. TWO ZERO ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO ZERO ON. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DR JENNIFER
BLAKE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
FOSTER CARE AND ADOPTION THE
VISTA DEL MAR. THANK YOU
SENATORS AND STAFF HERE TODAY
FOR ALLOWING US TO SHARE BOB.
THANKS FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
REINVEST IN AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKER. BOTH THE DIRECT SERVICE
WORK AND- RIGHT THERE I THINK.
FIRSTHAND THE DIFFICULTY
RECRUITING AND RETAINING
SPECIAL CALPERS WORKERS REPORTS
TO COMPETE WITH OTHER
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
MAYFIELD. I WANT TO SHARE VERY
SHORT PERSONAL STORY THAT I
BELIEVE ARE LIKE WHAT IS THAT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE. YOU YEARS IN MY I WAS
HEADING OUT. THAT CALLED HOME
TO BRING IT COLUMN AND THE
GRANDMOTHERS THE WEEKEND. YEAH
I HAVE A OF GIVING CARE A VERY
HARD TIME BUT OVER THE YEARS
AND ABOUT. WELL ANYONE YOU.
YEAH TO MEET PRIVATELY TALK
ABOUT HOW TAX HAS BEEN. ALLEN
ATTY KNOCKED ON DOOR THAT ME IS
THAT WAS READY OUT WHEN I TO
THE FRIEND THAT MIGHT IF THAT
IN MY TRUCK. IT LOOKS SHOCKED
BUT I USE MY ON A FACE TO THE
QUOTE THE DOOR THEY DIDN'T WORK
COMPARED THAT HE WAS GOING TO A
BOY RIGHT AROUND CAMPUS. MY OUT
OF THE MEETING BACK WITH MY
TRUNK EVEN IN THE CAR. WITH
BACK FOR THE OF THE CAR RIGHT I
A BIG HUG GOODBYE DAY. OUR
CHILDREN DON'T BECOME A- TO FOR
THE ON IS ON US TO GET THEM TO.
DOWN THANK. YOU CHECK. WHO ARE
HELPING. ME LINE UP TO THE-
THANK YOU KNOW. RATES DROP.
SEVENTY FOUR. FIVE PER. TO LESS
BELIEVE. I'LL MORE THAN. ONE
PROTECT ONCE. PROGRAMS CARE. TO
BUT HELP AT THE STATE TO BIG
TURNOVER AND INCREASE ON JAN OF
OUR- FIRST BECAME A- THERE PAT
AMP. THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ
OF THE NEXT. WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE'RE HERE
TO SUPPORT SEVERAL ITEMS THAT
ARE ONLY ARBITRATE ON ONE WE
ARE SUPPORTING ITEM NUMBER. ONE
THREE FOUR SIX SEVEN. NINE AND
TEN. BUT I REALLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT I DIDN'T DO WHICH IS.
REINVESTING AND FOSTER FAMILY
EIGHT THOUSAND WORKERS- AS WE
ALL KNOW BAD POSTURE CHILDREN
HAVE DRAMATICALLY ARE
DRAMATICALLY LESS LIKELY TO
ACHIEVE PERMANENCY- LAND BUT
ALSO WORK- CHANGES. AND MANY
SOCIAL WORKERS. AND THE
PROFESSION AND THEY MAY HAVE
COME FROM POVERTY THEMSELVES.
SO IN ORDER TO- I COULD KEEP
THEIR JOBS AND WORK THEIR
FAMILY IT'S VERY ARE. I AM TOO
I'M CONNECTED THAT SO WE NEED
ABLE TO RETAIN THESE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND GIVE THEM OUT OF
THE WAY EACH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TAX COURT PLEASE.
NINE TWO ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO ZERO SEVEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. MELENDEZ IN AN-
I MY NAME IS STEPHANIE PIPER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LINE. IMAGE
SERVICES AND I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF START IN RESIDENTS
WITH THEIR PROGRAMS THE S. T.
R. T. T. IN PROPOSING ITEM
NUMBERS AND- THIS IS A ONE TIME
REQUESTED FUNDED BRANT BROUGHT.
MACINNES TO BE DEVELOPED BY.
ADMINISTRATION SERVICES FOSTER
CARE RATES IN AUDITS BRANCH
IT'S A PROPOSAL THAT IS REALLY
ABOUT THE HEALTH SAFETY. AND
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU HAVE
COMMENTED ABOUT STABILITY FOR
THE HIGHEST NEEDS FOSTER YOUTH
RECEIVING SHORT TERM
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTION IN THE
S. T. R. T. P. E. S. T. R. T.
PIECE OF THE YOUR EXTRAORDINARY
COSTS PERSONNEL COSTS.
QUARANTINING PROCESS DELIVERY
CAPACITY SUPPLIES AND
EQUIPMENT- TAX FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING IN ADDITION TO LOSSES
OF REVENUE DIDN'T COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OR IF HE SAID. FROZEN
THEIR INTAKES. AND SO IN ORDER
TO STABILITY IN AN INSURED
HEALTH SAFETY BOTH OF THE AND
STAFF. WE HAVE SUBMITTED THIS
TO. WE WILL BE SHARING DETAILED
ANALYSIS OF EACH OF THESE ITEMS
WITH YOU. TO COME OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RECENTLY WE
SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER NINE
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS I AND
NUMBER TEN THE INSTANT
SUPPLEMENT AND FRANKLY EVERY
PROPOSAL IS GOING TO POSITIVELY
SUPPORT OUR USE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TWO ZERO EACH YEAR LINE IS OPEN
TWO ZERO EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS TOOK ME BAN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE. OR
CALIFORNIA CASA AGENDAS UNDER
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT
RELATING TO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
THE PORT THE TENTH PROPOSAL
LISTED EXTENDING THE INCIDENT
THAT WOMAN. CAME INTO START
THREE MONTHS PRIOR TO THE
EXPECTED DELIVERY DATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TO THIRTEEN
A LINE IS OPEN TWO ONE THREE.
HI MY NAME'S JACKIE HI SIR.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR CHILD I AM A SERVICE THAT.
I'M THINKING SLOWLY BECAUSE OF
THE ECHO. BUT THANK YOU FOR
LETTING US ALL TAKE YOUR TIME
CHANGE EKE OUT WE SUPPORT ALL
OF THESE VERY IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL AND- ALTOGETHER IT'S A
MODEST. REQUEST TO HELP OUR
CHILDREN IN THE U. THE GREEN
LINE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES SERVED BY
THE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS. WHO CARE FOR A 100%
AND YOU. SERVICES OFFERED CAN.
CHILDREN WHO OFTEN NEED A
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE. TEENAGER
MEDICALLY FRAGILE ISLAND.
CHILDREN WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES. BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONDITION I'M ACTUALLY SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED YOUTH. AFTER ANOTHER
WE ARE REQUESTING A BUDGET
REQUEST FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUND THAT HAS A FEDERAL
MATCH. REDUCE SOCIAL WORKER
TURNOVER. INCREASE PERMANENCY
FOR FOSTER YOUTH. FROM MULTIPLE
STUDIES THAT SHOW. THANK YOU
SEVENTY FOUR POINT 5% CHANCE OF
PERMANENCY WITH ONE OF THE
WORKERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE
WRITER KAMALA THE NEXT CALLER
AND I WOULD REMIND EVERYBODY IN
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE OR YOUR
DEVICE MODERATOR ARE AVAILABLE
TO OFFSET THIS BUDGET REQUEST.
WE'RE READY TO MOVE UP. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WHEN I'M ASKING YOU TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALL. I
COULD NOT INDICATION I HEAR YOU
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT CALL PLEASE AND I
WOULD REMIND EVERYBODY TO MUTE
YOUR PHONE OR DEVICE TO MAKE
SURE YOU DON'T HAVE AN ECHO.
THIS IS ALIGNED TO SEVENTY IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU SENATORS
AND STAFF FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
MY NAME IS WESLEY MATTHEWS AND
I WORK WITH ALTERNATIVE FAMILY
MEMBERS THIS BOXER FAMILY
AGENCY AND I'VE WORKED IN THE
FIELD FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
AND THAT TIME I HAVE WITNESSED
POSITIVE REUNIFICATION ALKON
AND PERMANENCY OUTCOMES AS A
RESULT OF SOCIAL WORKER RICH
STABILITY WITH THAT SAID I
SUPPORT PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
PROJECT MORE POSITIVE OUTCOMES
FOR EXCHANGE. I WAS LUCKY TO
RECENTLY AT TEN THE ADOPTION OF
TO SEVERELY DELAYED DELAYED
FOSTER YOU. DID SUCCESS STORY
OCCURRED BECAUSE OUR AGENCY
SOCIAL WORKER WAS ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE USE. AND RESEARCH
PARENTS FOR THE TIME- PLACEMENT
INTO THE TIME OF FINALIZATION
FOR ADOPTION. WHAT I AM SAYING
AGAIN I AM IN SUPPORT OF
PROPOSAL TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINANCIALLY
TENURE LINE IS OPEN TO AT AND
T'S. YES THEY ARE THANK YOU TO
SENATORS AND STAFF MY NAME IS
HECTOR LOUIS MIGHT BE US JUNIOR
I'M AT WORK WITH TLC CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES I BEEN
DESTINATION SHE'S BEEN AROUND
FOR OVER FORTY THREE YEARS I
PERSONALLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
FOSTER CARE AND ADOPTION. FOR
OVER TWENTY FOUR. I AM HERE ASK
TO CONSIDER- SUPPORT. NUMBER
TWO. NINE WE'RE IN AGENCY THAT-
A WIDE RANGE OF SERVICES- FAULT
CARADOC JANET HE R. T. P.
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM-
PUBLIC SCHOOL ONE OF THE-
CONTINUITY THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY AS SOCIAL WORKERS
THAT HAVE TENURE AND HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS ALTERNATELY YOU
KEEPING SIBLINGS TOGETHER AND
ASKING THEIR FAMILIES. TO STEP
IN AND- REALLY TO FIND- PLEASE
FOR SO AGAIN I WANT THANK YOU
YOUR- AND YOUR CONSIDERING AND
LOOK FORWARD TO. YOU'RE
SUPPORTING THESE MEASURES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. ONE MOMENT. TWO
NINETY ANNUAL LINE IS OPEN TO
NINETY IN. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ALEXIS AND ADVOCATES AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH HERE IN BOTH THE
PART OF THE HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
AUSTRIA WHICH INCLUDES THE
INFANT OPPONENT BEGINNING IN
THE SEVENTH MONTH OF PREGNANCY
FOR EXPECTANT AUSTRIA'S. I LOOK
AT THE YOUNGER SIBLING TO A
PARENT CAN YOU THINK CARE I SAW
FIRST HAND THE DIRECT
CHALLENGES AND DISPROPORTIONATE
HIGHER RATE OF COMPLICATIONS
DURING PREGNANCY. I MET WITH
SUPPORT PREVENTION RATHER THAN
REACTION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE.
TWO TWENTY FIVE BILL AND IS
OPEN TO TWO FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
JASON JOHN I'M FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION IN
COUNCIL AND- I AM ALSO A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT OUT OF SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA- THE
CALIFORNIA SO SHE'S BEEN
COUNSELED WE'RE REPRESENT OVER
SIX POINT THREE MILLION
STUDENTS K. THROUGH TWELVE-
ACROSS CALIFORNIA INCLUDING-
OUR OUR MUCH VALUED FOSTER CARE
POPULATION- THAT IS WHY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. ON BEHALF OF- OVER
HUNDRED TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS TO
SUPPORT- THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR POLICIES PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
THE INFANT THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENT NOW MORE THAN EVER
WITH- THE CHALLENGES PRESENTED
BY THE KOGAN NINETEEN PANDEMIC
IN A DISPROPORTIONATE. EFFECT
ON MARGINALIZED ALREADY
MARGINALIZED YOU HAVE CENTRAL
THAT WE EXPAND AS MUCH SUPPORT
AS WE CAN THOSE COMMUNITIES- WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ITEM SIX
AND NINE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY. MUCH READ
AMEND IT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MODERATOR GOOD
MORNING. ONE SIX ON A BILL AND
IS OPEN. ONE SIX FIVE. K. AS
TESTING AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES- WANDA.
STAR SUPPORT FOR DEPARTMENT
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL NUMBER ONE
WHICH WILL INCREASE LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCY FUNDING. TO THE
AMOUNT THAT WAS OUTLINED IN THE
NEW FUNDING METHODOLOGY. AND
THEN UNDER CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES THE IMPORT OF
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL NUMBER
FIVE. LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR PREVENTION SERVICES THAT
CAN HELP PREVENT CHILDREN
ENTERING CARE. NOT TO PROTEST
THE PROPOSAL FROM LATIN
PRESSLER INCREASED FIFTY R.
COSTA COUNTY HADN'T HEARD. FROM
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS. TO TOP THIRTY REQUIRED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO TWO EIGHT HILL AND
IS OPEN TO A- IT. WILL BE
CENTERED ON BEHALF OF THE AT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE
TO START BY REGISTERING SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF MY CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES WORKER'S FOR ITEM
THREE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO AUGMENT THE FAA FUNDING AS
WELL AS THE PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT SUBMITTED BY CHILD
SUPPORT DIRECTORS WITH BOTH THE
MISSION. ON BEHALF OF MY CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SPECIAL- I'D
LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT I
DON'T WANT YOU OR I A LOT.
UNDER THE- ACTION WOULD.
HIGHLIGHT ITEMS I STARTED.
WELFARE SERVICES AND I AM GLAD
THAT NOT ONLY FIND RSA OR WHAT.
THE WORKER NEED THE SERVICES
LIKE FRIENDS AND CALIFORNIA FOR
THE HOT IN CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ACROSS. FROM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MODERATOR TO CHIRLA
ANNUAL AND IS OPEN TO TWO NINE.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
BENEFITS AND STUFF. I AM HANNAH
MY NAME IS SUE EVAN AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF WALDRON
FAMILY SAID IT IS EIGHT CASH
AND TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AGENCY
SERVING SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
I AM HERE ON BEHALF TO SUPPORT
I TWO TWO ONE NINE. ALL OF THEM
HAVE A ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE DO YOU AND I AGENCY MANY
OF THEM HAVE SPECIALIZED
MEDICAL NEEDS THAT REQUIRED
SKILLS AND EXPERIENCE SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT WILL BE THAT FOR
THE CHILD AND FAMILY FROM THE
BEGINNING UNTIL THEY. COULD BE
REUNIFIED OR ADOPTED. IT IS HOW
GREAT WHEN I COULD TELL A LOT
THEIR JOB BUT NO LONGER. TO
STAY WORKING AND I AGENTS. IN
ADDITION I AM ON BEHALF OF A-
OF MORE A HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
TO IT RIGHT SUPPORT FOR THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION-
PREVENTING AND REDUCING. YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS THE PROPOSAL. IN
ADDITION I DO EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR ITEM NUMBER THREE SEVEN AND
TEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. TWO THREE
TWO YOU'LL LINE IS OPEN. TO
THREE TWO. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
THIS EVENING MY NAME IS BRIAN
VAN AND I'M A SOCIAL WORKER AND
AN ADMINISTRATOR FOR A FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY SERVING THE
CENTRAL SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND THE-
FRESHER AND EXPERIENCE WHEN
THEY LOSE THEIR AT A SOCIAL
WORKER AN INCREASE IN SOCIAL
ORDER IS A STRONG STEP TOWARDS
ATTRACT IN HAINING SOCIAL WORK
PROFESSIONAL. OR TABLE THOUGHT
YOU FOR REPAIR WORK. BECAUSE OF
THIS I AM IN FAVOR OF IT THE
BUDGET REQUEST AND ASK YOUR
SUPPORT. THE MUCH NEXT CALLER
IS OPEN ONE ONE THREE. HELLO MY
NAME IS. CRISTINA TOWARDS AT
ARE YOU IT WOULD JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES BUT. I AM I AM HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATION. FOR IF YOU
INVENTION AND WHAT DOES WHAT
DOES REDUCING FOSTER YOU REPORT.
I EXPERIENCE POSH- MY WHOLE
LIFE AND I WOULD HOME ONE.
BEING FROM A GREAT ONE IN THE-
THE EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM. BUT I BELIEVE THERE
WILL. I'M PUTTING WOULD BE
HELPFUL BANDING HOUSE. QUESTION
YOU ARE OUT HOW MUCH WE'RE GOOD
HERE- AT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS WEEK THANKS
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO THREE SEVEN HILL IS OPEN.
TO THREE SEVEN. HELLO EVERYONE
MY NAME OVER THE FJORD AND I
WITH THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA. I ALSO ONE OF
THE COORDINATORS BE PROJECT AND-
CALL. AND I'M HERE YOU ARE LATE
MARCOLA PARTY PRIMARILY HOW
TRYING TO BUY- EXAMINATION
LIMIT AB. IT WOULD HELP PUT
THAT- AGUIAR-CURRY ALL THE
GIANTS DRAFT THE AND THANK OF
GOVERNMENT. THAT INTERNET. ALSO
ACT THROUGH EIGHT I MEAN IT'S
ABOUT ALL TALK YOU BE GOING THE
TRIAL BUT A I'M ONLY I HAD AND
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
CHRISTOLOGY ECOLOGY I CAN. NOT
A BOOK EIGHT BY A- AND WHERE A
LOT OF. CALLING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLOR PLEASE. IN THE NEXT
YEAR YOU THREE I AM IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM NUMBER TWO ARE AGENCY
WORKERS HAD ESTABLISHED A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FOSTER
CHILDREN FOSTER PARENTS AND
MANY TIMES THEIR VALUE ARTICLE
FAMILY IN AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
GET THEM HOME. OUR WORKERS WORK
HARD AND NOW IT'S NOT. RIGHT
FOR THEM IF. AND NOT LEAVE
FOSTER CARE AGENCIES SOCIAL
WORKERS THOUGH JOB THAT THEY
LOVE BECAUSE THEY NO LONGER
ABLE TO. TAKE CARE OF THEIR
HOME AND THEY HAVE TO LOOK.
HIGHER PAYING JOBS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR HAVING ME
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MODERATOR CHIU
FORTY TO THE LINE IS OPEN. TO
FORTY TWO. YES HI MY NAME IS
MERRY FRAME I'M CALLING FROM ON
BEHALF OF WALDRON FAMILY
SERVICES AND I'M CALLING IN
JUNE REALLY JUST REITERATE A
LOT OF WAS INSPIRED. AND STAY
STRONG ON THE POINT THAT ARE
USED IN OUR FAMILIES REALLY
NEED THE SUPPORT OF THE
CONSISTENT SOURCE A WORKER TO
HELP THEM THROUGH ALL OF THE
STRUGGLES. AND STAY STABLE AND
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO CARE FOR
THE KIDS THAT COME INTO THEIR
HOMES. I AM DEFINITELY IN
SUPPORT OF- ONE TWO THREE FIVE
SIX SEVEN AND FINING HONDA.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP
SUPPORT FAMILIES WHO ARE CARING
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN DURING THIS TIME NEEDS
TO BE DONE THANK YOU. FEEL
BETTER FOR ELEVEN NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HELLO MODERATOR. ONE
SIX THIRTY A LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIX THREE SENIOR US. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEANNIE I
NEARLY- I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE SPEAR IN IT AS SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROVIDER AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. EVIDENTIAL
PROVIDERS HAVE STEPPED UP
DURING THIS UNPRECEDENTED TIME
TO SERVE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
HOUSTON RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
USE WHO HAVE HAD TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES. WE'VE INCURRED
ADDITIONAL COSTS RELATED TO
PERSONNEL RELATED TO
ACTIVITIES- OVER TIME THE KOBE
HEY- ALL OF THE SUPPLIES THAT
ARE NECESSARY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY JUST REALLY TRYING
TO KEEP OUR STAFF ENGAGED WHILE
ALL OF THE E. ARE MANY OF THE
OTHER SUPPORTS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY AVAILABLE TO OUR
CHILDREN. ARE NOT THERE ARE
STAFFERS SUPPORTING REMOTE
EDUCATION REMARK REMOTE
TELEHEALTH- ARE YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO GO AND ENGAGE IN THE
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY NORMALLY
WOULD HAVE SO PLEASE ASKING FOR
THAT CONSIDERATION ALSO
REFERENCING ITEM NUMBER TWO.
FOR THE FOSTE CARE SOCIAL
WORKER. PORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE.
MODERATOR CHIU FORTY EIGHT YEAR
LINE IS OPEN TO FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS RICKY ON THIRTEEN YEARS
OLD EARNS AN AUTOMATIC THE
CALIFORNIA CURRENT AND- BLIND
SHADE MYLIFE PLEASE KEEP
FINDING IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU.
TWO FORTY NINE A LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SPELLED.
NATIONAL CONTROLLER FOR OUR
LUNCH FROM THE TO THE POINTS
FOR HELPING YOU ALL FOR THE
LAST EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS WE ARE
REQUIRED IN APPROVAL FORTY
YARDS LEADING BUDGET. NUMBER
FROM ITEM SEVEN DIESEL THE BOOK
WOULD BE. READ THE DISEASE AND-
WILL. HOW CALLS. HERE CREASED
ABOUT ONE ONE DOLLARS. OKAY
ADDITIONAL STUFF WEEK WHAT DO.
ACCORDING TO THE CALL IF YOU
ONE FIVE IN ADDITION. WE RECKON
YOU LAW IS SURE TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR TO MOLD PARK OKAY YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO TO THREE LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR MIKE CARROLL
WITH THE WEAPONS FEDERAL LAW.
I'M CALLING TODAY ABOUT- THE
CHILD SUPPORT ISSUES IN YOUR
AGENDA. JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
THINK THE NOW IS VERY GOOD I
COMMEND IT TO- THE MEMBERS
LEGISLATOR TO READ I THINK IT
REASONABLE NUMBER OF ISSUE THAT
THAT'S COMMITTING THE
APOCRYPHON- FIRST OF ALL THOUGH
RIGHT BY DAN OF CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS OF THE LONG OVERDUE. AND
ENERGEN YOUR APPS ARE GENDER AB
WE APPROPRIATE- WE ALSO THINK
THAT IT'S TIME TO. STOP USING
THE TRIAL BEFORE AS A
REIMBURSEMENT AND FOR OUR
WELFARE SYSTEM THIS MONEY NEEDS
TO GO THROUGH THE CHILDREN NOT
THE STATE. AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE WOULD LIKE TO. A
OF IT ON THE- OF THE JOKE. BUT
I MEAN WHAT. FORWARD. TO VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. WE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR MUCH NICK COLOR
PLEASE. TWO FIVE ORDEAL AND IS
OPEN TO FIVE ALL. TWO FIFTY CAN
HEAR US. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
OKAY. TEN TO FIFTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU
SENATORS AND STAFF MY NAME I
YURI TOMORROW AND I'M A PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT STANFORD HERE ARE
USED AND FAMILIES. I SUPPORT
ALL OF THE PROPOSALS. FOR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES FROM TODAY AND
IN PARTICULAR ITEM NUMBER TWO
THE REINVESTMENT AND FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS.
SOCIAL WORKERS ABILITY DIRECTLY
IMPACTS THE STABILITY AND
PERMANENCY RATES OF YOUTH IN
OUR CARE AND THE RETENTION OF
OUR RESOURCE. THAT WE
CRITICALLY NEED. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME WHEN YOU'RE
IS ALSO IN MY FORMER STUDENTS
HELLO GLAD TO SEE YOU'RE STILL
DOING GOOD WORK NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU DR GRANT. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THAT
WAS A GOOD FINISH- I STILL
REMEMBER HER PAPER ON AN END OF
LIFE- SO I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY OF FORD TO SPENDING
THEIR MORNING AFTERNOON AND
EVENING HERE WITH US- WE VALUE
ALL THE IMPORT. I SHOULDN'T
WANT TO THANK ALL THE STAFF AND
DEPARTMENTS IN HERE IN THE
BUILDING- FOR THAT FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY IF YOU
DIDN'T GET TO MAKE A CALL AND
YOU STILL WANT TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS PLEASE YOU CAN EMAIL
US. OR CONTACT THE COMMITTEE WE
ARE VERY INTERESTED IN YOUR
PARTICIPATION- NOTHING FURTHER
THEN I WILL ADJOURN THIS IS
BUDGET SUB THREE MEETING.